Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten.
Irgendwie sind die NFTs auf einmal nix mehr wert.
Da musste die Originale verbrennen.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer 441 vom3. Oktober 222 auch bekannt als Tag der deutschen Geheimheit und,
da äh sind wir und blicken auf die Kurse, was was.
Der deutschen Geilheit hast du.
Einheit, Entschuldigung. Habe ich mich versprochen.
Ja, da hast du dich, glaube ich, total, ja.
Na sowas. Das mir jetzt so rausgerutscht. Kann ja mal passieren. Manchmal macht man so Kommentare,
ganz unkontrolliert. Ähm so ja äh wir haben uns äh zusammengefunden und wir haben äh heute auch noch eine, gestern dabei, nämlich Gradesi, hallo, herzlich willkommen wieder im Lobbuch Nes Boutique.
Guten Morgen. Genau, wir äh brauchten mal wieder ein Kompetenz-Upgrade und äh da dachten wir, reden wir einfach mal mit dir.
Genau, bevor wir dazu kommen, regen wir uns aber noch ein bisschen auf über andere Sachen.
NFT ist.
In einem in einem in einem ich kann das gar nicht in Worte fassen, wie völlig,
bescheuert Martin sein muss, der ein Bild von Frida Karlo,
offenbar in 10.000 NFTs von hochauflösenden Scans aufgeteilt hat,
jeden einzelnen davon für 4000 Dollar verkauft hat,
und dann das Originalbild von Frida Carlo aus dem Jahr 1944 verbrannt hat,
Dazu sagt, dass dieses Bild jetzt wie ein Phoenix aus der Asche,
in der in die in die Ewigkeit wiedergeboren wird. Wie völlig drüber muss der sein, ne? Normalerweise schickst du solche Leute halt irgendwie wohin, wo man ihnen hilft.
Äh außerdem hat er hat er das Bild ja nicht zerstört, weil,
Er hat es der Welt zurückgebracht, weil er lässt jetzt die ganze Welt es sehen. Äh denn es machte es es bringt der Welt jetzt mehr Gutes,
und es macht ein Statement, als wenn das jetzt einfach nur in seiner privaten Kollektion gesessen hätte. Wo du so denkst, so Junge, dann scannst du halt das ganze Bild und machst es der Welt verfügbar. Verkaufst nicht. Schnipsel-Scans,
für für tausenden Dollar und verbrennst dann das Bild. Also glücklicherweise,
Glücklicherweise ähm verstehen also Mexiko versteht so mit Frida Karlo scherzen ganz wenig Humor und der scheint jetzt also das nationale Institut der feinen Künste,
ist nicht amüsiert und äh suchen äh haben jetzt eine äh eine Untersuchung gestartet wegen äh kriminellem Vandalismus.
Krimineller Vandalismus.
Ich meine, ich kenne die mexikanischen Gesetze nicht, ne, aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen, man hört in Mexiko auch vom Gesetz der Straße und.
Gesetzer haben jetzt in der Regel jetzt nicht jetzt nicht unbedingt immer maß,
für die Aktion, die dort generell ergriffen werden. Ähm von daher könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass er nochmal von jemand anders auch noch auf die bekommt. Aber ich meine, das ist natürlich im Prinzip
äh die die Konsequenz des des radikal äh Kapitalismus.
Digitalen ja also wenn ihr dann sozusagen dein Digitalscheiß keiner mehr ab,
nehmen will, sowohl konkret als auch so inhaltlich, dann äh sorgst du einfach für eine Verknappung so. Und es geht natürlich hinten und vorne nicht auf. Aber das ähm.
Das geht sehr hinten und voll auf RTL. Also tatsächlich wird er sich ja auch überlegt haben, dass es also,
der wird sich das mit der Verknappung schon sehr genau überlegt haben, dass es vielleicht beispielsweise,
keinen so guten oder keinen vollständigen Scan dieses Bildes gibt. Ja und dann muss er natürlich, wenn er wenn du jetzt sagst, du möchtest ein Frida Kalobild in irgendwie in NFTs verkaufen, dann ist die notwendige Konsequenz,
du das Original halt zerstören musst, ne,
der hat halt, der hat halt wirklich einfach zu lange äh irgendwie mit den Cryptobros irgendwie Shisha geraucht oder sowas. Also es ist ja,
wie völlig durchgeknallt sind die Leute, ne? Und der der Punkt ist halt, weißt du, wenn wenn Bank sie,
Sein eigenes Bild teilzerstört und dadurch ein größeres Kunstwerk schafft, ja, dieser das Bild, was halb in den Schredder gerutscht ist, ne? Dann war es Banksy und nicht irgendein mexikanischer Kryptobruder, der irgendwie zu lange in der Sonne gestanden hat,
einfach boah eine katastrophale äh ja äh Katastrophe.
Es ist falsch auf allen Ebenen. Es ist vor allem schon falsch in der Annahme, dass in irgendeiner Form dieses NFT dieses Werk als solche ja irgendwie repräsentieren würde, was es ja nicht tut,
ja, sondern bestenfalls repräsentiert es
ein minderwertiges Abbild, der hat wahrscheinlich auch mal vorher mit seinem iPhone kurz äh draufgehalten, bevor er es weggeflammt hatte, wird es ja wohl nicht nach allen Regeln der äh Kunst, also so wie Museen ihre Werke äh digitalisieren.
Nicht beurteilen.
Können wir nicht beurteilen. Selbst wenn es so ist, ist das ja sozusagen immer noch nicht die Wahrheit, weil du müsstest ja äh na ja egal, braucht man eigentlich gar nicht drüber zu reden. Das ist halt einfach äh aber das ist das, was es was das eben mit den Leuten macht.
Ja, also sie haben einfach, sie sind einfach so freakisch auf äh Geld und rum aus, dass,
dass sie einfach äh bereit sind zu jedem Zeitpunkt dann auch gegen diese Interessen der Gesellschaft zu handeln und das macht diese ganze Bewegung so irregefährlich,
Uns wird halt ähm wenn der große Crash kommt
eh nochmal interessant zu sehen wie dann darauf reagiert wird. Ja also das ist dann sozusagen so äh wenn das alles so kleine Digital Putins, die sich dann,
zurückgedrängt sehen und dann irgendwie äh Nuklear antworten, ja. Das ist äh ist das ist das Problem.
Ne? Ihr seid doch echt alle gefailt so und jetzt werdet ihr einfach von der Resistenz auch weggebügelt.
Okay, ja, also kommen wir kommen wir zu zu ernsthafteren Themen.
Okay, meinetwegen.
Es dauert noch mit dem Crash. Ich sage ja, es dauert noch mit dem Crash. Das das die Kurse sind der der Crash die Bubble platzt erst, wenn sie eine ganze Volkswirtschaft ruinieren kann. Dazu ist sie gerade nicht in der Lage.
Ja, aber ich meine, Grafikkarten kriegt man jetzt zumindest wieder. Also so das ein oder andere lohnt sich halt schon nicht. Na ja gut, also man merkt schon, das das geht alles runter. Das ist einfach alles bekloppt, das muss auch sterben. Egal.
Dann haben wir über äh Zensurumgehungsmaßnahmen mit,
VPN Tor und Snow Flag und anderem gesprochen. Da haben sich mehrere Leute auch in wilden E-Mails äh bei mir beschwert, äh warum ich keinen VPN-Anbieter konkret empfehle.
Was erlaube äh Linus,
Asar äh schrieb zum Beispiel, äh wäre auch daran interessiert, was man am besten bezüglich VPN machen sollte. Verstehe, dass Linus nicht sagen will, welchen Anbieter er nutzt
außer zu sagen, dass man die günstigen kommerziellen Anbieter nicht nehmen kann, aber er könnte doch vielleicht sagen, worauf man achten sollte
oder vielleicht eine Reihe von Möglichkeiten auflisten, die Ähnliches anbieten, ohne eine bestimmte davon zu empfehlen und dadurch lässt man Hörerinnen die Wahl.
Ich habe doch Hörerinnen die Wahl gelassen. Ich habe ja gesagt, äh sucht euch einen aus. Ich habe ja alles gesagt, was man darauf beachten muss. Ihr habt noch irgendwie E-Mails bekommen, wo Leute, ja, welche Scipher muss ich denn benutzen oder äh also ein Quatsch?
Nee, darum geht's ja gar nicht. Also es geht bei der bei der Verwendung eines VPNs potenziell darum, in diesem Anwendungsfall, den wir jetzt besprochen haben,
einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu entgehen. Das bedeutet, ihr müsst in eine Juristin wo potenziell keine mehr gilt.
Ja, wenn jetzt Leute kommen und sagen, ich mache meinen eigenen VPN-Server, ja, supergute Idee, das ist aber dann auch nur deiner. Ja, dann kannst du genauso gut keinen nehmen,
wenn wenn es halt dein Eigener ist, den nur du verwendest, ja? Es geht ja dabei darum äh diese,
diese Dinge, diese IP-Spure zu vernichten, bringt zum Beispiel auch nichts, wenn man jetzt sagt, ich kaufe mir aber jetzt einen VPN-Server in Kanada, ja,
dann gehen deine IP-Pakete erkennbar von deinem Anschluss nach Kanada zu dieser einen IP komm erkennbar von da zurück. So kannst du dir also das Geld für einen VPN-Server,
Cover sich äh sparen. Aber grundsätzlich, wir machen hier keine Werbung. Das kommt euch sicherlich komisch vor,
Wir sind jetzt auch unserer Reichweite bewusst und ich weiß, wenn ich hier nur einen Hinweis geben würde, welchen VPN-Anbieter äh ich nehme
oder welchen ich ich persönlich nutze, dass das potenziell durchaus dazu führt, dass dieser äh VPN-Anbieter nennenswerten Zuwachs haben würde.
Wir machen das nicht für Geld und kostenlos auch nicht. Wir wir reden hier halt einfach äh die die Wahrheit nichts als die Wahrheit, so wahr uns Gott hilft. Ähm.
Schon religiös.
Religiös und nein, das ich habe da einen Vortrag drüber gehalten, was bei unterschiedlichen,
ähm Methoden der Anonymisierung zu beachten ist etwas nicht, den habe ich zusammengehalten mit,
Thorsten, den habe ich jetzt mal mit in die Shownotes getan und übrigens habe ich auch meinen anderen Vortrag über Kunst. Ich habe ja auch mal einen Vortrag über Kunst gehalten.
War ich ja sehr dankbar, dass ich einen Vortrag halten durfte über etwas wovon ich keine Ahnung hatte. Die habe ich auch mal in die Shownots getan.
Florian äh fügte dann noch hinzu wie immer guter Podcast, vielen Dank für die
allerdings hätte man diesmal auch erwähnen können, dass Darling nun auch im Iran aktiviert werden soll und dieses wahrscheinlich der Zugangsweg, den der Iran am wenigsten blockieren kann. Natürlich macht es Sinn
und zu kritisieren und seine Ziele und Methoden zu hinterfragen aber man sollte dann auch so fair sein und ihn erwähnen,
seine Technik einmal hilft. Wobei der Aufbau von auch nicht ungefährlich sein dürfte, abgesehen davon, dass man sie irgendwie ins Land bringen muss. Trotzdem werden sich hier in Zukunft neue Möglichkeiten der Zensurumgehung eröffnen, gerade dann
Smartphones immer häufiger direkt mit einem Satellitennetzwerk kommunizieren können. Ja ja ich weiß es ist auch nicht ohne die Kontrolle über das Internet in die Hand von privaten Firmen zu legen, aber wenn man sieht
Politikern im Iran, in China und in Russland so einfällt, weiß ich auch nicht, was besser ist. Die Diskussion zur Proxis und VPN werden also relevant bleiben.
Also eine kostet äh wenn ich hier gerade schaue 460 Euro,
äh dann 80 Euro im Monat, das ist zumindest das Standardding, was sie mir äh äh was wir hier empfohlen wird, gibt's wahrscheinlich keine billigeren.
Ähm damit wird der Iran jetzt nicht gerettet werden.
Und was du aber natürlich sehr sicher erkennst oder sehr richtig erkennst, ist, dass Starlink,
Schon mal drüber gesprochen, für die USA eine geostrategische Bedeutung hat. Das heißt, es geht hier,
nicht nur darum, dass Elon Masken Internetservice macht, sondern dass die USA eine stabile Internetversorgung oder eine für sie vertrauenswürdige Internetversorgung,
dahin bringen können, wo Sie, die gerne hätten und das ist doch genau der Grund, dass die Chinesen jetzt auch so ein Ding bauen,
Es geht hier nicht darum, ob eine Privatunternehmen irgendwo Internet hinbringt oder dass Elon Musk der Heilsbringer ist, sondern mit dieser Technologie,
Internet irgendwo hinzubringen, ist erklärtes Ziel der USA. Es ist halt das auch nicht notwendigerweise ein falsches Ziel der USA, aber es ist schon,
länger so, ich glaube hier auch schon wieder ein paar Jahre her, dass die USA natürlich, was auch die Seite ist, die ich, sage ich mal, ähm.
Äh sympathisch finde ihre Strategie, ihre Geo-Strategie auf na ja zensurfreiheit, öffentlichen Zugang zu Informationen,
gesetzt haben, um Ländern, die mit Informationskontrolle arbeiten, also beispielsweise äh China, Russland äh hier entgegenzutreten mit einer anderen Strategie,
Das ist äh nicht erst heute so und das auch nicht erst seit Darling so. Ähm deswegen werden ja zum Beispiel auch Projekte wie Tor äh nicht nicht wenig und auch Signal nicht wenig von dem Außenministerium,
gefördert oder von Unterorganisation des Außenministeriums äh vor ein paar Jahren darüber gesprochen,
über den Open Open Tech Fund, der zum Beispiel Signal und Tor nennenswert gefördert hat, wo ich auch schon in Projekten mitgearbeitet habe, die vom Open Tech Fund gefördert wurden und ähm,
Das ist sicherlich nicht falsch. Denke das Problem, was wir jetzt gerade eigentlich als Welt haben, ist, dass diese Mächte, gegen die man da mal vorgehen wollte.
Inzwischen äh eher die Schwachstellen der des freien Informationszugangs und der Zensurfreiheit ausnutzen,
sie die gleichen Probleme bei sich selber dicht machen und das ist auch das was in der letzten Sendung gesagt habe mit so ein paar Starling-Antennen, wie es jetzt nicht den Iran wieder online bringen.
Und ähm auch wenn es Möglichkeiten der Zensurumgehung gibt, ist es halt immer ein bisschen traurig spät, die dann jetzt äh spät und spontan,
einzurichten.
Am Ende wird man auch sehen müssen, wie langfristig sich die gesamte äh Netzpolitik von Starlink dort
entwickelt, das wissen wir heute nicht. Wir kennen den Zustand wie's jetzt ist. Jetzt funktioniert das halt erstmal. Hat zum Beispiel auch großen Nutzen, gerade für die Ukraine. Ähm so als strategische Waffe. Nur,
was künftig dann an Regulationen durch die USA noch auf dieses Netz herab regnen wird und dann ist es ja im Wesentlichen durch die USA,
reguliert, weil ich denke nicht, dass sie sich von irgendjemand anders da herein äh regulieren lassen werden. Ähm das wird sich dann halt noch zeigen, womit wir
worüber wir dann reden. Von daher würde ich jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass irgendwie gut oder schlecht. Ich meine, es funktioniert. Das kann man mal, glaube ich, bestätigen so, also es hat äh,
In diesem Sommer mir eine ganze Menge Internet äh besorgt, wo ich sonst keins gehabt hätte. Das ist schon mal ganz praktisch. Ähm aber ich würd's jetzt deswegen auch nicht äh,
als Leuchtfackel äh der neu gewonnenen Freiheit äh feiern, auch wenn's,
derzeit in seiner Anbindung durchaus dazu beitragen kann. Aber im Iran denke ich mal wird am Ende die Entwicklung doch sehr viel mehr von,
der Waffengleichheit oder der nicht existierenden Waffengleichheit äh definiert werden ist noch vollkommen offen, wie das ausgeht.
Dann hat noch was kommentiert.
Genau, Dinus schlug in der Sendung vor ORBOT zu installieren. Dieses als VPN zu nutzen und den Single-Traffic dann darüber zu leiten, sofern ich das richtig verstand. Das Problem hier ist, dass Single nur ODP Traffic macht. Tor wiederum versteht nur
TCP Traffic. Das heißt, die Signalanrufe würden immer an Tor vorbei ins Netz gehen.
Ist also hier keine Hilfe. Man könnte mit einem Tunnel arbeiten, das ist fehleranfällig,
gibt wiederum einen Teil der Anonymität auf und ist auch langsam. Für Telefonate insgesamt eine schlechte Idee. Bezüglich Snowflake würde ich Linus raten, einfach ein wenig zu warten, die Nutzerinnen kommen nicht sofort nach dem Aktivieren des Plug-ins.
Ja, also stimmt, TCP äh gibt's also es gibt über Toren nur TCP. Ich äh.
Kurze Brücke äh schlagen für die Leute, die mit diesen Begriffen doch nicht so viel anfangen äh können. Also das Internet, was ihr da sozusagen immer äh macht, nicht? Das,
das teilt sich in dem Wesentlichen im Großen genau in diese zwei Arten von Kommunikation
So für alles, was so Verbindung ist, jede Webseite, die ihr klickt, das läuft in der Regel über TCP. Aber diese etwas äh spezielleren Anwendungen, insbesondere, die so ausfallsicher sein wollen und irgendwie Echtzeit
machen et cetera verwenden oft UDP.
Eher umgekehrt
Ausfallsicherheit hast du bei TCP durch das Transmission Control Protokoll wo du mit drin hast, dass wenn ein äh Ding nicht ankommt, dass das Paket wiederkommt und bei UDP hast du's nicht.
Es ist richtig, es ist eingebaut ins Protokoll, aber wenn die Programme das selber sozusagen in die Hand nehmen wollen und nicht so machen wollen, wie es TCP macht, dann benutzen sie UDP.
Ist ja auch letztlich im Detail egal
Wichtig ist nur, diese beiden äh sind sozusagen die beiden Kernkomponenten des Internet, was ihr sprecht und darauf beziehen wir uns hier.
Okay, also Echtzeitanwendung, UDP, äh weniger Fehleranfällige äh Anwendungen, TCP, so kann man das, glaube ich, zusammenfassen. Ähm,
Und genau, ist korrekt. Thor macht nur TCP, kein UDP. Das hat ein bisschen äh oder hat hat verschiedene Gründe,
unter anderem, dass es wahrscheinlich sehr schwierig würde für die Torserver zurück mit zurückkommenden UDP-Paketen ähm umzugehen,
Ähm deswegen ja für Signal halt äh die Proxis,
ich hab tatsächlich weiß ich nicht ob die Nachrichten bei Signal auch über ODP versende werden würde mich ehrlich gesagt wundern da würde ich eher mit TCP rechnen entsprechend äh,
habe ich wie richtig sagt äh auch gedacht, dass es funktionieren würde. Äh telefonieren bin ich eh nicht so der Fan von. Zu Snow Flake,
Ja, also ich habe das äh tatsächlich in diesem Browser-Plug-in ist bei mir auch in der Stunden nichts passiert. Ähm ich habe aber dann mal den äh Snow Flake Proxy einfach auf einem Server installiert.
Der wirft,
üblicherweise jetzt im Schnitt geguckt in Richtung 300 Verbindungen pro Stunde und äh macht zwei Gigabit ab und ungefähr fünfhundert MB dauern.
Auch mal sechshundert. Das kann man auch auf einem machen,
Zuhause bei mir macht äh pro Stunde 12 Verbindungen 30 MB ab und sechs MB down, also ist der Server,
auf jeden Fall praktischer oder auf jeden Fall sehr viel,
leistungsfähiger. Ich weiß nicht, woran es liegt, also keiner erstens daran liegen, dass er jetzt natürlich auch besser kann äh oder einfach an seiner statischbleibenden IP. Aber ähm ja, kann man auf jeden Fall es ist äh ohne größere Probleme,
ähm anwendbar und wenn das als Browser-Plugin nicht sofort funktioniert, na ja, ich ich,
machen bei der Browser auch wieder zu. Insofern habe ich's lieber auf einem äh Server installiert. Dann hat noch jemand über 30 kommentiert.
Linus beschreibt VDS so, als ob jeder einzelne TCP-Verbindung gespeichert wird. War das tatsächlich jemals der Plan oder Gesetz? Ich habe nur in Erinnerung, dass wer beziehungsweise welcher Anschluss hat wann welche IP-Adresse gehabt, gespeichert werden sollte.
Also da gibt es natürlich den Wikipedia Eintrag Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Deutschland Inhalt des Gesetzes, ja? 2tausend7er Gesetz,
Nach dem Gesetz mussten die folgenden sechs Daten erfasst werden und durften maximal sieben Monate lang auf Vorrat gespeichert werden. Erstens, Anbieter von Telefondiensten, einschließlich Mobilfunk und Internettelefondiensten speichern.
Die Rufnummer oder andere Kennung des Anrufenden,
und angerufenen Anschlusses sowie im Falle von um- oder Weiterschaltung jeweils weiteren beteiligten Anschlusses. Den Beginn und das Ende der Verbindung nach Datum und Uhrzeit unter Angabe des der zugrunde liegenden Zeitzone.
In Fällen, in dem im Rahmen des Telefondienstes unterschiedliche Dienste genutzt werden können, Angaben zu dem genutzten Dienst,
im Falle mobiler Telefondienste ferner die internationale Kennung für mobile Teilnehmer des Anrufenden und angerufenen Anschluss die internationale Erkennung des anrufenden und anrufenden Endgerätes,
Also das wäre immer schöner, also das eine ist die äh Insi und das andere ist die IMEI, also die International,
Mobile Subscriber Identity und dem International mobile ähm Equipment Identifire. Die Bezeichnung,
der durch den Anrufen oder der anrufenden Anschluss bei Beginn der Verbindung genutzten Funkzellen, also hier das hatten wir,
letzte Mal gesagt also wo du dich befindest. Im Fall im Voraus bezahlt er anonymer Dienste auch die 1te Aktivierung des Dienstes nach Datum, Uhrzeit und Beschreibung der Funkzelle. Im Fall von Internettelefondiensten auch die Internetprotokolladresse des Anrufenden
und des angerufenen Anschlusses. Also hier schon einmal IPs von,
Internettelefoniediensten, ja? Ähm.
Das gilt entsprechend bei der Ermittlung einer kurz Multimedia oder ähnlichen Nachricht. Hierbei sind die Zeitpunkte des Versendes und der Empfang des äh und des Empfangs der Nachricht zu speichern. Das gilt jetzt nur für Telefon,
Internet, Mobilfunk und Internettelefondienste. So und da ist der Punkt, an dem hier der kommentierende, jemand über äh dreißig, genau den Punkt hat, die,
die Daten werden an unterschiedlichen,
Stellen gespeichert, denn das äh der Inhalt des Gesetzes geht's weiter an Bieter von äh Diensten der elektronischen Post, also E-Mail nicht,
Internetservice Provider.
Bei Versendung einer Nachricht. Die Kellung des elektronischen Postfachs und die Internetprotokoll-Adresse des Absenders sowie die Kennung des elektronischen Postfach jedes Empfängers der Nachricht, also,
äh IP-Adressen und ähm,
E-Mail-Meterdaten bei Eingang einer Nachricht in dem elektronischen Postfach die Kennung des elektronischen Postfasses Absenders und des Empfängers der Nachricht sowie die Internetprotokolladresse der absenden Telekommunikationsanlage. Bei Zugriff,
auf das elektronische Postfach dessen Kennung und die Internetfotograsse es abrufen, denn die Zeitpunkte, der in der Nummer 1 bis3 genutzten Nutzungen des Dienstes nach Datum, nutzt sein Angebot und so weiter.
Und am Ende speichern dann die Anbieter von Internetzugangsdiensten, die dem Teilnehmer,
für eine Internetnutzung zugewiesene Internetprotokolladresse, die eindeutige Kennung des Anschlusses über den die Internetnutzung erfolgt und den Beginn und das Ende der
Internetnutzung unter der zugewiesenen Internetprotokolladresse nach da für Uhrzeit untergrundeliegenden Zeitzone.
Stimmt also, dass die Internetzugangsdienste nur speichern müssen, wer wann welche IP hatte.
Gleichzeitig die Telefondienste aber speichern müssen äh weitere Metadaten jeweils unter dem,
Datum, IP-Adresse oder unter dem Adresse, sodass diese Daten wieder zusammengeführt werden können.
Und äh können, sollen. Ähm,
Also, jemand über 30 hat hier äh größtenteils recht, dass die der Internetservice Provider,
sofern er nicht auch Telefonie anbietet, was er ja tut und Internettelefonie anbietet, was er ja auch tut,
Potenziell nur die IP speichern muss, während die Dienstanbieter dann gezwungen sind, die IP-Adresse zu speichern, um dann,
darüber die ähjenigen, die sie genutzt haben, identifizieren zu können. Einfach, ne?
Fast so gut wie europäische Gesetzgebung würde ich sagen.
Die kamen ja aus einer äh oder nee, war das das erste deutsche Vorsatz? Äh.
Vorsatzdaten.
Da bin ich noch nicht mal sicher,
dass auch ursprünglich die EU Richtlinie umsetzen sollte oder schon mal so ein erster Anlauf war.
Äh da bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher. Aber okay,
einmal alles und was sehr spannend ist, finde ich hier, dass dass
auch sogar die IMEI und die IMSI gespeichert werden sollen, nur um mal nur ich glaube mit und da werden wir uns in einer äh kommenden Sendung noch ein bisschen auseinandersetzen, weil ähm ich mich da in letzter Zeit auch ein bisschen mit auseinander
gesetzt habe.
Und.
So ein bisschen, ja.
Gut dann sind wir durch mit dem Feedback, oder?
Ich denke schon, ja. Dann ein ein Thema, was ich gerne in der Sendung haben wollte, Thema aber nicht.
Das letzte Mal habt ihr darüber gesprochen, als ich das letzte Mal da war,
gefühlt.
Das ist äh das ist einfach das ist.
Lass es raus, komm.
Nein, wir nehmen das jetzt rein.
Ja du musst es rauslassen, damit es, damit es, damit du's verarbeiten kannst, damit es einfach mental ja, in dich geht.
Im Rahmen dieser äh Auseinandersetzung zwischen äh Elon Musk und Twitter wurden jetzt seine äh E-Mails und äh Kurznachrichten,
Als Beweismittel vor Gericht eingesetzt und in diese Konsequenz auch öffentlich zugänglich,
betrifft im Zeitraum und Twitter. Und,
ich meine, wir haben ja in Deutschland den Springer Verlag, der äh ja
Ich glaube ungefähr das ist, was Elon Musk auf Twitter machen wollte und sich natürlich auch unmittelbar angesprochen fühlte als ähm Twitter oder als Elon Musk beabsichtigt hat oder seine Absicht angekündigt hat, Twitter zu kaufen.
Und die ersten Deutschen, die bei Musk halt anklopfen sind Döpfner und,
Matthias Döpfner ist der Vorstandsvorsitzende des Springer Verlags. Der
wie der Spiegel schön titelt, wochenlang erfolglos um Max Aufmerksamkeit buhlte, nämlich ihn überzeugen wollte, dass Musk Twitter kauft und das von Springer für ihn managen lässt.
In besten Händen, weil Axel Spreer Verlag. Das wäre doch mal was.
So Alter was ist was erlaube? Wie fertig sind die? Ja,
Also wie ich also der gefriert einem doch das Blut in den Adern, wenn du denkst, da wird Twitter was wirklich ausreichend problematisch ist, ja.
Von Elon Musk gekauft. Die Story ist ja noch schlimmer als ich dachte. Und dann kommt irgendwie Döffner äh,
und und sagt, ja komm hier das finde ich doch toll und äh wir machen hier eine freie Meinungsäußerungsplattform, weil also der Döpfner ist ja auch tatsächlich, ne? Den merkt man jetzt immer mehr,
Ein Verschwörungstheoretiker, ne? Der Typ kontrolliert seit Jahrzehnten die die Meinungskontrolle in Deutschland über über die Idioten, ja?
Und,
weil ihnen jetzt mal ein bisschen Gegenwind äh entgegenfährt, weil sie die bittere Erfahrung machen, dass sie nicht mehr diktieren, wer in Deutschland gewählt wird und weil sie die bittere Erfahrung machen, dass wenn ihr
ähm wenn ihr Bild Chefredakteur, da die die Redaktion mehr oder weniger als Haare betrachtet und in der ihr irgendwie äh
den Leuten vor gefälschte Scheidungsurkunden vorliegt, um sie irgendwie flachlegen zu können. Wenn das nicht mehr geht, ja, dann ist das auf einmal die Meinungsdiktatur, der sich ein Matthias Döpfner nicht mehr,
beugen mag und da muss er muss Maske für ihn Twitter kaufen,
Damit's wieder echte Meinungsfreiheit gibt, die diese doch völlig durchgedreht.
Dieses schöne Mähbild, wo so äh Honecker und noch ein paar andere Auguren irgendwie so beim Gläschen Sekt rumstehen und sich alle ordentlich beömmeln in dem Foto,
das ist so das das Bild, was ich so ein bisschen im Kopf habe so bei bei Elon Mach so und dann hat mich der Döpfner angerufen und hat gesagt hey lass mich doch Twitter managen.
Muss die Content-Moderation ja machen, wenn die Chat-Kontrolle kommt.
Meine Sorge ist eher äh meine Sorge ist eher, dass dass sie sich da tatsächlich also was für Gespräche müssen die geführt haben,
überhaupt auf die Idee kommt, ja? Am 14. April nimmt Döffner nochmal als noch ein letztes Mal den Faden auf und schreib Mask
unser Chefredakteur der Welt hat in einem Interview gerade erklärt, warum er Twitter verlässt, was er kritisiert, ist genau, was du wahrscheinlich ändern willst. Zwei Tage zuvor hatte Weltchefredakteur Ulf Poschert,
im Interview. Im Interview mit der Zeit seinen Rückzug von Twitter angekündigt,
Und es als national moralistische Zauberbude voller Spießer bezeichnet. Wenn Ulf Bosch hat ist halt einfach mal so,
also ich weiß nicht genau, was er also der hat ja eh,
ein sehr sehr eigentümlicher Ansichten aber in in Ulf Poschardts Welt ist Ulf Poschert kein Spießer sondern alle anderen ja und ähm,
Döpfner nutzte den Twitter-Ausstieg seines Chefredakteurs, um sich bei Masken noch einmal ins Gespräch zu bringen. Ich würde sehr gern über Twitters Zukunft diskutieren, wenn du bereit bist, so aufregend.
Der kriecht hier.
Das scheint schon eine gewisse erotische Erfahrung.
Ich finde das auch ich finde das so äh so so bitter äh und traurig zu sehen, wie irgendwie der Springerchef da noch Elon Musk in den Arsch kriecht. Das ist doch,
Wie läuft's da kalt und den Rücken runter, deswegen wollte ich das noch mal ähm erzählen.
Haben wir das jetzt verarbeitet.
Dann lass uns doch mal über die erfreulichen Dinge reden.
Genau denn äh du gehst auf Reisen, Khalesi und äh kommst ein bisschen rum in Europa, stimmt's?
In Brüssel.
Alles nur dank der Chatkontrolle. Endlich kann ich reisen.
Mhm. Nee, aber erzähl doch mal so ein bisschen. Du warst auf einer äh auf einer Konferenz.
Ja genau, Anfang äh September war die Freedom vier, das ist eine äh digitale Menschenrechtskonferenz, die jedes Jahr stattfindet und jetzt auch wieder in Präsenz stattfinden konnte, die es immer ein Wochenende in Brüssel.
Und da trifft sich so ein bisschen die äh europäische äh,
digitale Menschenrechte, Szene, sehr Deutschland dominiert, ganz überraschend. Ähm genau und im.
Aber jetzt auch nicht also.
Na ja, also ein Großteil der Teilnehmenden sind halt.
Aus Deutschland. Alles klar.
Und im Rahmen dieser Konferenz haben wir natürlich auch das EU-Parlament besucht, weil wenn man schon mal da ist, dann muss man das ja auch mitnehmen.
Ist das sozusagen von der Konferenz schon her organisiert worden oder hast du das nochmal separat angeleiert?
Genau zu dieser Konferenz gehört immer an dem Montag nach dem Wochenende ein Parlament.
Ach, das gehört da sozusagen dazu, das ist so das Social-Event.
Genau, das ist das Social-Event und ähm,
dann sind dann immer ein, zwei Parlamentarier da, die sich dann auch mit den Teilnehmenden,
und Bilder machen und solche Geschichte,
Parlamentarier halt zu machen, wenn sie mit sich mit der Zivilgesellschaft treffen.
Hast du auch Bilder gemacht?
Äh nee. Ich bin nicht so der Fan von Bilder machen, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Nee, weiß ich nicht. Äh fühle ich nicht so, würde.
Bist nicht so der Selfie-Typ meinst du? Nee, weiß ich nicht. Mhm, kann ich verstehen. Aber erzähl doch mal, äh war das dein erster Besuch im Parlament?
Ja tatsächlich.
Und wie äh kam das so rüber für dich?
Also ich glaube, man kann, wenn man in Brüssel ist, sein ganzes Leben in diesem Parlament verbringen. Ähm es gibt da gefühlt alles äh so von Friseur über Café, Kiosk äh.
Alles haben die da oben.
Haben wir alle.
Diesel Klopapier, Mehl.
Betten habe ich nicht gesehen, muss ich ehrlich.
Die da oben.
Die sollen ja auch nicht schlafen, die sollen ja arbeiten, ne?
Stapel von Waschmaschinen.
Ähm ja, also es ist ein ein kleines Dorf äh Sicherheitskontrollen sind so ein bisschen wie,
Flughafen würde ich sagen ähm,
Ja, es ist total witzig, weil wirklich alle Menschen da rumrennen diesen Parlament arbeiten und man wirklich dann doch wenn man sie dann erkennt, an den ein oder anderen Europaparlamentsabgeordneten einfach so auf dem Flur äh trifft. Ähm,
Ich glaube, das Faszinierendste an an der an dem Plenarsaal fand ich die Übersetzerinnen Boxen,
und wie die da arbeiten müssen, das ist wirklich faszinierend, wie die das schaffen, wenn so viele Sprachen so schnell das zu übersetzen.
Ich meine, das macht man sicher dann.
Na den machen doch wahrscheinlich für jede Sprache eine Person, oder?
Nee, zwei Personen,
ich glaube sogar nee ich meine sogar drei und das Interessante ist ja aber dass nicht jede Person jede Sprache spricht, das heißt je nachdem welche Nation gerade spricht
gibt es eine entweder meistens ist es halt dann Englisch oder Französisch oder Deutsch und von der aus übersetzen die dann weiter. Das ist tatsächlich so ein bisschen fast wie Stille Post an einigen Stellen. Also es ist wirklich äh faszin.
Übersetzen dann weiter. Geht mal ein Beispiel jetzt und welche.
Na ja, also es kann sein, dass du als eine Übersetzerin, zum Beispiel jetzt ich nehme mal jemanden, der Katalan spricht und seine Rede hält, aber es können ja nicht alle Übersetzerinnen.
Ach so und dann wird es von Katalanen auf Englisch und dann aus dem Englischen ah ja logisch klar das skaliert ja nicht. Ja ja.
Englisch auf alle anderen weiteren Sprachen, weil es können ja nicht alle Übersetzer, alle Sprachen sprechen, wenn du nur drei Übersetzer pro Sprache in dieser Bo.
Also nicht nur stille Post, sondern auch äh Delay, also es dauert dann eben auch.
Ich meine, ich finde das in gewisser Hinsicht finde ich das ja total faszinierend an der Europäischen Union, dass das einfach auch mal so konsequent durchgeführt wird so, wenn so Amerikaner auf sowas blicken,
denen ist halt irgendwie alles Englisch so, das ist einfach, ne? Okay, gut, ähm theoretisch auch noch Spanisch, aber im politischen Prozess findet das halt nicht statt,
In Europa muss das halt einfach gemacht werden mit jeder Kacksprache, die da irgendwie noch um die Ecke kommt und äh die muss dann halt auch noch mit dabei sein und das finde ich auch richtig und wichtig, dass das gemacht wird, aber ist natürlich für den politischen Prozess auch ein Ex.
Prima Aufwand.
Ja, auf jeden Fall und es ist natürlich auch echt interessant, also wir saßen, konnten einer Ausschusssitzung mit,
anhören, die an dem Tag stattgefunden hat und man hört ja dann auch, dass die Laie so da war, der ähm also das ist total interessant, weil man kann sich in so Ausschusssitzungen setzen und dann sah es da einfach der tschechische ähm,
Innenminister und hat eine Rede gehalten. Ich glaube so,
50 Meter Luftlinie von mir weg und ich meine so Staatspolitikerinnen sieht man jetzt nicht so häufig so nah und äh kann den einfach so zuhören, das ist schon sehr äh so real dann da zu sitzen.
Vielleicht zufällig gerade Fange? Hättest du ja noch eine Unterschrift abholen können.
Nein, definitiv nicht. Das war ganz furchtbar. Nee, das war ganz furchtbar. Ich glaube, da hätte ich hätte ich andere lieber gehabt. Ähm.
Aber klar, ne, also auf einmal wird's ich war ja auch mal da Linus so auch, ne? Das,
würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass das ein komplett überrollt, aber es war einfach schön zu sehen, dass äh das wird auf einmal so greifbar, anfassbar äh real auch, dass dieser Prozess tatsächlich stattfindet und sich nicht nur in Medien abspielt.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also ich glaube, wer da mal wirklich so Luft schnuppern will, es gibt eine sehr lustige, französische TV-Serie, die heißt Parlament. Von einem jungen äh Parlamentsmitarbeiter, der kurz nach Brexit anfängt im EU-Parlament zu arbeiten,
und äh,
diese Serie fast greift diese Stimmung im EU-Parlament so generell supergut auf. Kann ich sehr empfehlen. Ähm es ist sehr unterhaltsam. Ähm auf deiner der Plattform deiner deines Vertrauens.
Vielleicht könnte das sein.
Das weiß ich nicht. Linus äh macht das doch bestimmt spezifischer fest.
Pirat Bay. Nicht ohne VPN, ne?
Äh wieder nicht.
Ich habe den Wikipedia Artikel mal in die Shownotes gepackt.
Europäische Fernsehserie heißt es ja bei äh Wikipedia. Finde ich ja mal eine interessante Bezeichnung.
Also es ist sehr, sehr lustig. Kann ich wirklich empfehlen.
Mhm.
Palamo oder wie.
Ja, genau. Also das Witzige ist äh
Ja genau, das Witzige ist, ihr braucht sie auch in in keiner also ihr braucht sie nicht in Deutsch euch zu organisieren, weil alle Personen, die sie in diese Serie vorkommt in ihrer Original-Landessprache sprechen und es dann immer nur Untertitel dazu gibt, was ja auch so ein bisschen der,
Realität entspricht im EU-Parlament.
Angeblich ist sie auf dem Fernsehsender One auf Deutsch schon erschienen.
Ja, aber sie ist schon wieder weg.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es den gibt.
Ja, aber es ist öffentlicher Rundkunden, die werden ja dann immer nach ich weiß nicht, wie viel Zeit wieder.
Okay, aber das ist so ein so ein Satelliten und und und Internet-Stream only äh Fernsehsender interessant. Es gibt.
Okay.
Ich gucke ja schon lang kein Fernsehen mehr, von daher. Na gut, dann müssen wir gucken, ob's da vielleicht eine Sicherheitskopie gibt. Anyway, also du warst da und es war schön.
Es war surreal.
Es war surreal, okay, gut, ne? Surreal ist hat ja auch was für sich. Aber du weißt ja eigentlich aus Gründen,
Also du bist ja sozusagen oder hast du die Gelegenheit auch genutzt in Sachen Chatkontrolle, auf die wir jetzt gleich zu sprechen kommen werden, dort auch Gespräche zu führen oder war das eher so,
andere Dinge, die da zur Sprache kamen. Worüber hat man sich dann mit den Abgeordneten unterhalten und welche haben sich da überhaupt gestellt?
Na ja also dieser organisierte Besuch ist natürlich sehr ähm,
Muss ich vorstellen, da sind dann irgendwie so 50 netzpolitische Aktivistinnen, die auf einen Abgeordneten,
losrennen ähm und wir, was sehr interessant war, war ähm Saskia, das ist eine französische Abgeordnete, die auch im Pegasus Ausschuss sitzt. Die hat ein bisschen aus ihrer Arbeit berichtet,
im Plenum. Ähm dann haben wir ähm natürlich auch Patrick Breier da gehabt ähm und ähm haben mit denen,
mit ihm gesprochen. Ähm genau, das waren so
Mir fällt die dritte Abgeordnete, mit der wir auch noch äh mit der wir diese 50 Leute auch noch gesprochen haben, nicht ein, aber ähm das ist dann eher mehr ein eine Berichterstattung von den Abgeordneten, was sie gerade alles so machen und dann beantworten sie noch ein paar Fragen.
Genau.
Okay, bis auf Tuchfühlung gehen.
Und dann hattet ihr noch einzelnere Gespräche oder weil's immer seid ihr immer mit 50 Leuten da rein marschiert.
Na ja, also bei den Besuchstags hatten wir nur diese fünf also es war dann, also die waren dann auch teilweise ein bisschen aufgeteilt. Die einen sind dann zu gegangen, die anderen haben sich damit Patrick getroffen,
in so einem kleineren Rahmen ähm,
Das kam natürlich auch schon sehr drauf an, aus welchen Mitgliedsstaaten die Aktivistie kommen und für was sie was sie für wichtig oder sinnvoll erachten, mit welchen Politikern die gerade sprechen wollen.
Alexandra noch getroffen hat? Habt ihr nicht getroffen, okay? Ich wollte nur beraten.
Äh nee ähm mir fällt's nicht ein. Es steht aber bestimmt auf der Freedom not 4 Seite vermutlich. Aber ich war auch also wie gesagt, ich ähm,
War in der Patrick Breier Gruppe. Deswegen kann ich, kann ich dazu nichts mehr sagen.
Und wie sein allgemeines äh Gefühl machen die ihre Arbeit da ordentlich?
Also die, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, ähm im Rahmen dieses Montagsbesuchs auf jeden Fall. Ähm aber ich glaube, das kann man schwer beurteilen, weil die natürlich extrem an extrem vielen,
Files heißt es ja äh im in der EU Parlaments äh Sprache arbeiten und klar kann man natürlich dann sagen so,
Mit Patrick redet man dann natürlich über die Chat-Kontrolle irgendwie, weil das ein Thema für ihn ist und mit der Saskia spricht man dann über ihre Arbeit im Pegasusausschuss, ähm aber in so einem großen Rahmen kann man das auch, glaube ich, gar nicht beurteilen.
Es ist, glaube ich, einfach sehr, sehr viel an Dingen, die da dann immer rauskommen und durchgepeitscht werden.
Ja das ist ja so ein bisschen meine meine Sorge immer oder oder mein,
ja, meine Sorge mit diesem politischen Prozess, dass er eigentlich sagt, ja wir haben hier ein Parlament und die diskutieren die Dinge, aber die delegieren natürlich auch oder äh haben dann ihre Berichterstatter und dann hast du den
am Ende hast du eine Politikerin oder eine sehr kleine Gruppe, die am Ende etwas auskämpft. Und die,
den anderen im Prinzip zu den zu den anderen Leuten ihrer äh,
was weiß ich nicht, ihre Koalition oder ihrer ihrer ihrer Gang zurückkommt und sagt, Leute, machen wir so und so, ne,
und da dann immer darauf zu vertrauen oder zu hoffen, dass da wirklich auch jeweils die richtige Kompetenz,
zum Zuge kommt das erscheint mir so ein bisschen riskant.
Vielleicht müssen wir einmal kurz erklären, wie das in der europäischen Gesetzgebung funktioniert. Ähm,
passt eigentlich ganz gut zur Chatkontrolle, also wir hatten ja irgendwie der zur Sendung, glaube ich, im Mai, als die Verordnung vorgestellt wurde,
Jetzt sind wir sozusagen im nächsten Schritt in diesem EU-Gesetzgebungsprozess. Ähm das heißt, die Verordnung geht an Parlament und Rat,
und im Parlament passiert genau das, was Linus ähm gerade angesprochen hat. Das heißt ähm dieses Gesetz wird an bestimmte Ausschüsse,
also zugeordnet, die dann sozusagen die Führung übernehmen ähm in der Meinungsvergabe, das heißt, die ähm,
erstellen, einen Report, ähm der wird federführend durch einen sogenannten erstellt. Ein ist der Berichterstatter, ähm der ist das eine Person, also ein Abgeordneter oder ein Abgeordneter, die entweder schon mal zu ähnlichen Filets gearbeitet hat oder
gesamt sich mit dem Themenkomplex auskennt. Ähm.
Idealerweise.
Idealerweise, genau, das ist natürlich total wünschenswert und auch irgendwie Fachwissen hat,
und dann kommt nämlich dazu, dass jede ähm.
Ne? Jede Gruppe noch sogenannte Shadows benennt, die dann halt die Berichterstatter ähm für die einzelnen Fraktionen sind.
Und da das dann halt mit diskutieren und am Ende kommt halt ein ähm bei raus, der halt Änderungsvorschläge zu diesen Entwürfen enthält und äh diese Änderungsvorschläge,
abgestimmt werden. Genau und an der Stelle sind wir jetzt gerade also die Chatkontrolle ähm wurde jetzt,
es scheint, interessanterweise an ähm den Liebeausschuss, der Liebeausschuss ist das Comedy on civil limities, Justice in Home Affairs, ähm das ist auch ein Ausschuss, in dem zum Beispiel Patrick drin ist.
Ähm das ist interessant, weil,
Wir erinnern uns ähm an diese Gesetzgebung, die ist ähm,
Unter Artikel 114ähm der allgemeinen Funktionen der EU aufgehängt. Das das ist die Regelung für den internen Markt.
Natürlich auch ein Committee für den internen Markt und das ist die Frage steht natürlich im Raum warum kriegt das liebe Komitee das und äh das also das Comedy für den internen Markt äh bekommt keine Kompetenzen für dieses Pfeil. Ähm,
ist so eine Frage, die grade noch so ein bisschen im Raum steht.
Ähm und dann gibt es halt zusätzlich zu diesem Lied-Autschuss immer noch Ausschüsse, die eine Opinion haben können. Die machen dann auch so einen Draft-Report. Ähm und können dann ihre Meinung zu diesem Pfeil abgeben.
Okay, aber also wer schreibt das? Also wer wer kann aktiv daran mitwirken, was drinsteht und was nicht? Das scheint ja der der relevante Faktor zu sein, ne?
Das machen die die Rapiteurs sozusagen in ihrem Komitee unter sich dann aus. Mhm. Grundsätzlich kann aber also nicht in dem Sim-Report, aber grundsätzlich können alle Abgeordneten Änderungsvorschläge stellen.
Ja genau, aber wer wer sagt äh wer sagt den den habe ich jetzt mal ernst genommen und den nicht.
Na ja, also das ist ja halt diese Idee. Dieser Report ist sozusagen die Empfehlung der Fachgruppe.
Und dann können die MIPs halt entsprechend also die Abgeordneten des Parlaments ähm Entschuldigung ähm dann entsprechend entscheiden, ob sie dann halt mitstimmen und in der Regel stimmen sie dann halt einfach mit dieser Fachmeinung mit.
Weil die natürlich keine Zeit haben, also diese Abstimmlisten, ich weiß nicht, ob jemand von euch das schon mal gesehen hat, die haben halt so zweiundvierzig Punkte, die innerhalb von irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, wie viel Minuten runtergerattert werden. Die haben so drei Knöpfe auf ihrem Tisch und müssen dann immer,
Fass drücken sozusagen, um abzustimmen.
Es ist echt gut optimiert bei den was ähm,
Was ist denn dein also wer sind denn jetzt die relevanten Reporteure für Chatkontrolle? Also weil's ja du hast jetzt so viele Ausschüsse genannt, jetzt ist immer die Frage klar, in welchem ist es nicht, wie viele gibt's überhaupt? Das kriegen wir die glaube ich gar nicht alle aufgezählt, oder?
Sind nicht so viele. Also es ist halt.
Insgesamt sitzen nicht so viele oder.
Wie viele Ausschüsse es insgesamt gibt oder wie viele es Ausschüsse es gibt, die an der Chatkontrolle arbeiten.
Genau, es also insgesamt.
Die kriege ich nicht zusammen. Ich weiß die nur die die für mich wichtig.
Kontrolle sind so drei bis vier relevante.
Genau es sind vier insgesamt. Also es ist einmal wie gesagt schon dieser liebe Ausschuss also und die haben am,
der internal Markets Ausschuss ähm dann Kult, das ist das Comedy für Kultur und ähm Bildung ähm und ähm FEM, das ist das Committee für Frauenrechte und ähm genderquality.
Genau, das sind so die drei, die noch eine Opinion haben. Ähm es steht immer noch im Raum,
Ob das so bleiben wird, wie gesagt, weil die Rechtsbasis halt eine ist für den internen Markt. Das heißt, das kann ähm theoretisch nochmal gechallengt werden. Das wissen wir aber noch nicht.
Ähm und es sind auch noch nicht alle Rappers bekannt. Ähm das ist nämlich so, dass ähm,
Es gibt dazu eine Seite, wo man dieses Pfeil verfolgen kann. Habe ich euch auch schon in die Shows getan. Ähm und man sieht da halt,
immer nur den Rapiteur, der,
esignt wurde und das sind derzeit erst zwei, die uns bekannt sind. Ähm für Imko ist das ähm Alexander Agio Saliba ähm von der SND aus Malta.
Und äh für Kult ist es einer dessen Namen ich nicht aussprechen kann, deswegen werde ich's gar nicht erst versuchen ähm
von den Linken. Ähm bei Liebe wissen wir leider noch nicht offiziell, ähm wer das äh Ganze.
Machen wird. Ähm es gibt halt immer so Vermutungen, aber noch nichts Offizielles und dann gibt's natürlich noch die Shadow-Ryperturce
dass es dann immer ein bisschen schwieriger rauszufinden, wer das denn für die einzelnen Fraktionen ist. Es steht jetzt nicht auf dem in dem in der in dem Precedure File drin. Ähm wer das ist.
Wie ist es denn, wenn also welche Leute geht das nicht irgendwie immer streng Reihe um, wer dran ist,
ja mit den je nach Partei oder Fraktion oder so.
Also wie gesagt, es kommt drauf an, ähm ist meistens wirklich so, dass es sind, die vorher schon an ähnlichen Files gearbeitet haben, zum Beispiel in Imko ist es ja ähm,
und hat zum Beispiel sehr viel am Digital Markets Act gearbeitet, das heißt der kennt sich halt mit diesen Digitalthemen und Plattform-Regulierungen gut aus und deswegen ist der jetzt halt da der Rapiteur.
Oma nach Kompetenz.
Ist das aus ausgehandelter Kompetenz, würde ich sagen, auch in einigen Fällen,
Also das kann natürlich also das es gibt das heißt tatsächlich das Komitee dass diese macht heißt tatsächlich die Abkürzung ist tatsächlich CCC ähm,
Zufall? Ähm und äh das ähm kümmert sich halt da drum und es scheint das und das ist dann halt wirklich Aushandlungssache auch in einigen Fällen.
Wie muss ich mir das denn vorstellen? Weil also eigentlich, wenn irgendwo Arbeit verteilt wird, stehen die Leute ja nicht unbedingt in der ersten Reihe. Wie ist das da?
Ja das kommt halt natürlich drauf an. Also ähm,
dieses ähm Pfeil, das kann man auch so ein bisschen so sagen, das ist auch die Stimmung in diesem EU- im EU-Parlament, das halt einfach,
hochexplosiv, ähm im Sinne von, man kann sich da echt die Finger dran verbrennen, ähm jedenfalls politisch aus der Sicht von vielen Abgeordneten.
Natürlich so zwei Lager. Ähm das eine Lager ist natürlich das von den äh Hardcore Kinderschützern, die sagen,
alles, was nur irgendwie die Lage hier verbessert, muss getan werden und diese Regulierung ist die beste Option dafür.
Na vor allem gibt's ja diejenigen, die wahrscheinlich also machen wir uns nix vor. Die wollen doch da alle irgendwie ihre Arbeit machen, um wiedergewählt zu werden.
Das ist nämlich die nächste Probleme.
Geschützt. Das ist doch also ich meine, wer kann sich was schöneres vorstellen?
Ist doch super und dann noch mit Internet, modern, ja, das ist so also das ist doch wirklich die perfekte äh die perfekte Bratwurst für irgendsoeine Bratwurst.
Genau, also es wird natürlich einige geben, die dann also jetzt vielleicht bei der Republik ist und was anderes, aber die dann Shadow Reporteur werden, um sich das auf ihre Fahne schreiben zu können. Ähm,
und dann gibt's natürlich die andere Gruppe, die das eigentlich für eine ziemlich blöde Idee hält, diese ganze Geschichte.
Ähm und dann gibt es halt die, die sagen, na ja, ich halte das für eine blöde Idee und ich äh schmeiße mich jetzt auch in diesen Kampf. Ich werde zwar vielleicht nicht sagen, dass ich's komplett ablehne, aber ich werde alles dafür tun, dass wir das soweit verbessern, dass es irgendwie niemandem mehr weh tut,
Und dann gibt's natürlich dieser die Leute sagen, die sagen so nee, fasse ich nicht an und ich möchte eigentlich auch nicht damit.
Will ich einfach nur außer der außer wer will weiter von weg sein, weil der riecht nach Ärger.
Genau. Ich äh stimme dann halt irgendwie mit. Genau, das gibt's natürlich auch. Ähm,
Das ist so ein bisschen auch fast auch die Stimmung zu diesem Pfeil im EU-Parlament ganz gut zusammen.
Okay. Und äh also äh und deswegen ist auch noch nicht erkennbar, dass da irgendjemand wäre, der oder die ja, in Frage käme.
Du meinst jetzt als Rapper? Ja. Na ja, es gibt natürlich eine ähm äh,
Protection Group, ich kriege grad den ganzen Namen nichts zusammen, die einige Mitglieder haben und es ist anzunehmen, dass wahrscheinlich jemand aus dieser Gruppe Reputeur für Liebe wird, was eine Vollkatastrophe wäre, weil das ähm wahrscheinlich jemanden aus äh aus der EP-Fraktion wäre.
EVP. Was ist EP?
Die Fraktion von CDU und Co sozusagen.
So
Politikparty.
In Deutsch, ist Deutsch, in Deutsch heißt sie äh europäische Volkspartei. Also.
Kenne immer nur die englischen.
Also nennen die sich äh.
Ja, das ist auch echt krass im Parlament, also ist überall EPP-Werbung und wirklich in so groß, wenn du da durchläufst, auf allen Screens, ja.
Werben für sich selber im Parlament. Ja. Wie völlig blöd müsst du den für dich selber in einem Parlament zu wählen?
Werbung ist in, da könnt ihr jetzt auch Werbung für Coca-Cola stehen oder irgendwie.
Ja, also einfach so EPP-Logos und irgendwelche Sprüche und es war in dem in der Zeit, in dem Zeitraum, wir haben uns auch versucht, in dieses Village zu schmuggeln, muss ich so geben.
EPP Youth äh Party Days oder so ähm und da war ein riesen Village vor dem Europaparlament
für die EPP-Leute aufgebaut und dann saßen wir da saßen vor diesem Parlament, da sind so Liegestühle und dann haben wir so überlegt, was so ablaufen könnte in in diesen Zelten und dann sagt
Viktor ähm so ja ich kann dir das ziemlich genau sagen und genau in diesem Moment fing an so richtig laut Vivaldi.
Aus diesem European Youth Willish zu spielen und wir saßen da so und dachten so, es ist jetzt echt nicht nicht ernst gemeint, oder?
Die Jugendlichen, die ködert man mit Musik, habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Mit wie weit die,
Aber hier ist irgendwie an mir vorbeigegangen. Ich bin hier auch schon fast alt.
Es ist mein.
Man sieht das nicht, worauf die Kids wirklich stehen.
Die rumrennen äh irgendwie aus den Achtzigern, dann sind die bald bei Vivaldi wieder.
Sind die großen Trends? Jugendsprache verstehen wir ja auch nicht.
Ich verstehe Jugendsprache.
Ja von aus deiner Generation.
Welches hast? Software as avice.
Dort kommst du bestimmt gut an in der Hood.
Aber ich glaube irgendeine Tagesschausprecherin hat das doch neulich so schön aufgesagt.
Äh
Deswegen.
Achso, habe ich nicht zugeguckt.
Nachholen, Bildungslücke.
Zu zwei.
Schreibt man das? SOS. SOS SOS?
SOS. SOS? Ja, U. Meine ich zumindest.
Also ähm in der Schulkommunikation heißt das.
Oh Sers ist kurz vorm.
Das kennst du nicht. Hier siehst du mal, wie gut du.
Ey, wenn wenn Kinder irgendwie halbe englische Wörter.
Halt ein bisschen cringe.
Bisschen.
Die Aufmerksame ist halt auf 15 Sekunden begrenzt, deswegen muss man die Wörter auch abkürzen.
Ja, wir haben das alles eingeleitet, bist selber schuld irgendwie mit unseren ganzen Leuten und äh anderen Chatabkürzungen und so weiter. Das war auch eine Form von Chatkontrolle, dass man halt irgendwie den Chat unter Kontrolle kriegt und da man irgendwie so wenig Zeichen über die Leitung bekommen hat, muss man eben alles kurz machen.
So und ja. Aber jetzt sind wir mental AFK.
Wir sind raus.
Okay ähm ja super diese EP Menschen. Ähm kann man nicht anders sagen.
Mhm. Kann man nicht anders sagen. Was machen wir mit den Kindern.
Aber ich weiß es nicht. Wir haben uns ja gedacht, vielleicht können wir uns da reinschmuggeln und so ein Bett holen und da in diesem Village rumlaufen und man musste sich irgendwie vorher groß anmelden, deswegen.
Nicht gemacht.
Ja weil das die Anmelde der Anmeldezeitraum vorbei, weil wir haben das ja erst in dem Moment festgestellt, dass wir da waren. Also nächstes Jahr.
Euch euch Hacker schicke ich da nur mal hin.
Wir haben schon überlegt, wie viel das wohl kostet, so ein Village davor aufzubauen und wir das einfach selber machen sollten, so mit Peng oder so.
Aber sag mal bitte also warum werben warum werben die für sich selber in einem Parlament? Ich meine die da sind die eine,
Die eine Gruppe, also warum machst du das? Ich meine, ist der der eine Ort, wo du wirklich nicht für deine Partei werben muss? Es sei denn, du musst irgendwie so die innere Moral aufrecht erhalten, ne?
Es auf eine andere Art und Weise. Nee, so wir sind wichtig. Ja. Wir sind wirklich wichtig.
Uns das hier unser, ist hier unser.
Das ist so, genau, das ist so die die eigene Gruppe wird äh sozusagen da adressiert und wir sind einfach total wichtig. Wir können hier sogar Werbeplakate aufhängen.
Faszinierend.
So ist es. Sowas passiert jetzt mit der Chatkontrolle.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Also wir können weitermachen mit, die Kommission hat seine Hausaufgaben nicht gemacht. Ähm,
Es ist superwitzig, also am 7. August hat Johansen einen Blogpost geschrieben. Johansen ist äh die,
genau, die diesen ganzen Kram rausgehauen hat und.
Hat den Blogpost geschrieben?
Um uns mitzuteilen, dass ihre Zahlen, ihre technologischen total akkurat sind. Ähm also sie schreibt, ähm
Ich lese das jetzt mal im Original vor. Die
warte es geht weiter, es geht weiter. Can beset at ninety nine point nine percent and example
Zero Point One Ford Positive Raide Subjector Human Review. Das hat sie in ihrem Blogartikel geschrieben.
Also kurz gesagt, äh Caesar, also,
Genau. 90 Prozent, das das gibt's schon heute und wir kommen auf 99,neun Prozent.
Nee, sie können eine äh auf 99,9 Prozent setzen.
Es gibt immer zwei, es gibt im also.
Ich meine, das ist so ein bisschen wie mit unserer Internetleitung funktioniert in 9neunzig Kommaäh.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, es gibt die es gibt die äh Präzision und es gibt die bei solchen Modellen. Immer.
Wenn ich sage, das Ding erkennt mit 99,9 Prozent Genauigkeit, ja? Dann gibt es ja den,
Also dann dann ist die Frage, wovon denn? Also er kennt es 99,9 Prozent des Materiales, ja,
dann könnte es natürlich sein, dass es auch noch eine ganze Menge außerdem hat,
um 99Prozent des Materials zu erkennen. Deswegen sagt man in der Regel Sensitivität, also korrektes Material, korrekt erkennen und den umgekehrten Fall spezifiziert, wenn du etwas erkannt hast, war auch das korrekt.
Ja? Weil du kannst die Sensitivität immer auf 100 Prozent kriegen, indem du einfach 100 Prozent folgst positiv auch noch mit dazu hast,
Und äh die Spezifität ist ähm das Entscheidende, aber wenn du sagst, wir haben eine Genauigkeit von 99,9 Prozent und dann bleibt 0,1 Prozent über, dann ist machst du genau den Fehler,
Nämlich zu dass du nur sagst, das was wir erkennen, es sind 99,9 Prozent der Fälle korrekt erkannt, aber das bedeutet nicht, dass die Fehlerrate dann 0,01 ist. Die die die du den Review gibst.
Es ist es ist.
Es ist schwierig zu äh erklären und ähm für Politiker noch schwieriger zu verstehen. Das Lustige an dieser ganzen Geschichte ist, wir haben da natürlich gedacht, so gut, wir würden jetzt eigentlich gerne wissen,
woher sie das hat. Also hat Felix Reeder mal einformation request gestellt. Ähm und die Kommission,
so ein bisschen dumm, weil also
Informationsfreiheitsanfragen auf europäischer Ebene ist es auch so, dass es eine Regelung gibt, also 15 Tage und dann müssen sie Zugriff auf die ähm Dokumente geben und ähm
Ansonsten müssen Sie einen Grund für die Verzögerung angeben oder von der Sonderfallregelung Gebrauch machen? Die EU-Kommission noch immer von der Sonderfallregelung gebraucht und dieses Mal,
haben sie die sehr lustige Antwort gegeben, dass äh sie sich auf eine Ausnahme berufen, weil sie andere Dienste der Kommission befragen müssten, um an diese Information zu kommen. Also die EU-Kommission schreibt einen Blogpost, in der sie sich auf Zahlen bezieht,
kann aber nicht die Referenzen zu diesen Zahlen liefern, weil sie dafür andere,
Dienste konsultieren müssten und deswegen haben sie Verlängerungsfrist eingereicht, aber auch eigentlich immer noch nicht geantwortet. Ähm,
Das ist nur so der eine witzige Teil dieser gesamten äh Informationsfreiheitsanfrage. Wir sind sehr gespannt, äh welche Datenlage sie uns jetzt irgendwann mal hoffentlich liefern werden.
Total süß.
Habe ich dir jetzt dieses Wort beigebracht. Aber ihr müsst ja auch eine jüngere Zielgruppe ansprechen.
Find's ja eher cringe.
Ja, ich fand's.
Mich nicht so richtig entscheiden.
Was sagst du denn?
Gar nichts. Ich lese ja EU-Gesetzestexte. Ich kann solche Wörter gar nicht.
Subsidiaritätsprinzip oder so sage ich dann. Na ja, also das ist äh der Stand der.
Man könnte eigentlich jedem, jedem Menschen, ne, also immer in dem Moment und das auch wirklich also ich stolpere ja selber oft genug drüber, ne? Aber in dem Moment, wo Prozente ins Spiel kommen,
Vorsicht! Vorsicht! Ich wurde ja hier auch schon mal korrigiert, was denn da musst du Prozentpunkte sagen und,
könnte man jedem Menschen nur zu Vorsicht raten, inklusive, in dem Moment, wovon Prozent die Rede ist und du daraus irgendeine Ableitung machst. Vorsicht.
Und die Prozente sagen auch oft nicht das, was äh also noch nicht mal das, was man fühlt ist richtig, ja? Also weiß noch, wie so Internetprovider in Deutschland mit 99 prozentiger Ausfallsicherheit äh geworben haben, wo ich mir dachte, so was,
sehe ich genauso pro Jahr irgendwie geht dreieinhalb Tage das Internet nicht. Habt ihr sie noch alle? Nee dann doch schon 99,9 so mhm ja toll.
Ja, SLA sind wichtig. Ähm.
Und was sie und Grundgesamt halten natürlich auch, ne? Wenn du sagst, wir müssen nur 0,1 Prozent der Kommunikation Europas manuell kontrollieren,
sollte dir kurz der Gedanke kommen, so hm wie viele Leute brauchst du jetzt.
Ja, also wie gesagt, das ist äh es ist äh ganz wild ähm und ähm die hat diesen Blogpost geschrieben, um zu sagen, dass ähm wir uns alle nicht so aufregen sollen und die Technologie ja da ist. Ähm,
Ja.
Gläubigkeit.
Kann ich da kann man.
Ja, okay, also dieser Blockpost ist, glaube ich, auch schon etwas länger her, oder? 7. August. Ja.
7. August. Ja. Also das ist schon länger her, aber seitdem ist auch nicht mehr viel gekommen. Deswegen also es ist auch wir haben ja wie gesagt immer noch keine Antwort auf die Quelle von.
Die hätte sicher auch einfach irgendwo ausm ausm.
Na ja so viel zu äh der Kommission, die nicht weiß, äh wie man Hausaufgaben macht, ähm,
was was ist noch so rumgeflogen? Ähm es,
Ist natürlich auch so, dass ich noch ein paar andere Stimmen zu Wort gemeldet haben, die ähm ihr, glaube ich, noch nicht genannt habt, äh der Lobbyverband von Mieter Amazon und Co möchte natürlich auch mitspielen. Ähm sie haben sich dagegen sie haben sich nicht komplett dagegen geäußert,
aber sie haben sich dagegen ausgesprochen, ähm weil äh das rechtlich ähm das Verbot allgemeiner Überwachungspflichten ähm,
gegen das Verbot allgemeine Überwachungspflichten verstoßen würde und ähm Mensch die Privatsphäre aller Menschen und andere fundamentare Grundrechte.
Angreifen würde und ein verschlüsselte Kommunikation untergraben würde. Also alles Dinge, die wir auch schon gesagt haben sehenden Meter, Amazon und Co.
In ihrer Lobby-Arganisation genauso.
Okay und was also hört auf die jemand? Nee ne, weil die EU ja immer denkt sich ey jetzt kommt also das äh muss ja eigentlich in der Regel wird sie gar nicht auf deiner Seite haben.
Also ja also wir können also es gibt den ersten Kompromissvorschlag die tschechische Ratspräsidentschaft gemacht hat können wir gleich nochmal drüber
was die äh da jetzt reingehauen haben. Ähm aber erstmal
Immerhin haben sie sich geäußert und sich nicht auf die Seite von unseren Freunden von äh echten Kutscher und vorn geschlagen. Ähm,
nochmal zur Erinnerung vorn ist eine Kinderschutzorganisation aus den Staaten, die insbesondere von Asten Kutscher gefangen wird und an das Vor und angegliedert gibt es ein super tolles Start-ups Start-up, das heißt Safer superkreativ,
ähm und das äh stellt,
eigentlich alle Technologien vor äh her angeblich. Es gibt keine wirklich gute Datenbasis dazu, ähm die alles umsetzen könnte, was in diesem EU-Gesetzesentwurf.
Steht,
Und äh vorn macht natürlich auch eine Kampagne. Ähm inklusive Werbung äh für Funding in Kim Kardashian-Workout-Videos. Ähm.
Kardashian-Workout-Video.
Die hat Workout Videos.
Klingt ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen so, als wärst du da nur zwei Klicks entfernt von dem, wovon wovor die dich beschützen,
Kannst du ja.
Das kann schon sein.
Zielgruppengerecht muss man das ja auch gestalten, ne? Genau, aber.
Ja. Oder den Kindern noch ganz anderen mentalen Stress zu bereiten.
Genau, aber vorn macht auch eine eigene Kampagne, in der sie sozusagen Werbung für diese Gesetzgebung des äh der EU-Kommission macht. Die finden das nämlich natürlich total toll. Die haben auch einen eigenen Brief geschrieben und das Interessante ist.
Eigenen Brief geschrieben.
Ja
Kim Kardashian oder ohne?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Lippenstift, hallo? Nein, aber ähm da haben natürlich auch viele Organisationen unterschrieben und es gibt aber auch die ersten Organisationen, zum Beispiel die Stiftung Bildung aus Deutschland,
ihre Unterschrift auf dem Lether von vorne zurückgezogen haben äh mit der Begründung ähm dass sie der Überzeugung äh sind, dass das geplante Gesetz nicht,
ähm den Nutzen bringen wird äh von dem wir von dem sie Anfang an ausgegangen sind. Also auch eine Kinderschutzorganisation, die dann festgestellt hat, hm, vielleicht doch nicht so gut ähm,
zu unterstützen. Ähm genau und,
Für alle, die noch mal äh das ganze Bashing haben wollen, was alles problematisch an ähm,
An diesem Gesetzesentwurf ist äh gibt es eine sehr schöne kleine Videoserie Serie von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, in der Felix Reeder ähm in kurzen Videos erklärt,
Das alles Mist ist.
Ähm und wenn wir jetzt schon mal bei Mist sind, können wir auch mal über den Kompromissvorschlag den die tschechische Ratspräsidentschaft gebracht hat, sprechen,
so ein Kompromissvorschlag sieht in der Regel ähm Streichung vor oder und fügt neue Teile in diesen Gesetzesentwurf hinzu und ähm das Interessante an deren,
ähm Kompromissvorschlag ist tatsächlich, ähm dass es sich primär um das ganze Thema Netzsperren dreht. Ähm bei den Streichungen und den Ergänzungen und sie einfach alle Grundrechtsabwägungen ähm,
gestrichen haben aus diesem Gesetzesentwurf im Hinblick auf Netzsperren.
Der Kompromissvorschlag ist, alle. Lasst uns die lasst uns die Grundrechtsabwägung einfach streichen, dann müssen wir dann nicht mehr so lange drüber streiten.
Genau, also im Hinblick auf Netzsperren, muss man immer noch dazu sagen. Okay. Ähm und dass sie auch nach wie vor ähm URL-Sperren realisieren wollen und keiner weiß, wie die sich das vorstellen,
Und es wird noch lustiger. Also vorher war's so, dass sie gesagt haben, na ja, wenn Providerinnen, die außerhalb der EU legen, sich,
weigern, Löschanfragen zu bearbeiten, dann die kompetenten Behörden,
Netzsperren gegen die verhängen dürfen. So ähm.
Eine generelle Einschränkung auf kompetente Behörden fände ich sowieso mal überflüssig. Überfällig, sorry, aber okay, das.
Na ja also das also das Problem ist in dem Wording ist ja. Also die Mitgliedsstaaten dürfen ja kompetente Behörden benennen.
Benennen. So ähnlich wie mit diesem wirksamen Kopierschutz. Der wird auch vor Gesetz benannt statt wirksam zu sein. Okay, sorry.
Na ja auf jeden Fall ähm haben sie das ähm jetzt soweit ausgebaut, dass diese,
kompetenten Behörden jegliche Art von Netz äh sperren gegen jegliche Art von hängen dürfen. Vorher war's nur gegen bekanntes Material. Jetzt ist es jegliches Material, wo man sich halt auch fragt so,
wie wollen Sie sich denn das jetzt vorstellen? Ähm und natürlich dürfen Sie nach wie vor die URL-Sperren realisieren, wenn Sie wollen, gegen außerhalb der EU liegende ProviderIn.
Ähm das ähm ist erstmal so eine Sache und
bei diesen ganzen Netzwerken Thema haben sie jetzt auch gesagt na ja also vorher war's halt wirklich so ähm hatten sie halt relativ viele
Selfguards zu sagen, okay, es muss nachgewiesen werden, dass die genutzt werden, um Material runterzuladen. Das EU-Center, also dieses tolle an Europol-Agnetisches Center muss verifizieren, dass das wirklich uralt sind, die problematisch ist.
Alles weghaben.
Genau und ähm,
ähm auch keine Grundrechtsabwägung im Hinblick auf zum Beispiel Freedom of Information äh mehr erfolgen wird oder auch auf negative Folgen für NutzerInnen. Ähm.
In welcher Form ist das jetzt ein Kompromiss? Das ist ja einfach also.
Na ja, das ist ja Ihr Kompromissvorschlag. Also es ist ja wie Sie wie die sich den Kompromiss vorstellen,
jeder malt ja sein Bild von dem Kompromiss wes den Sachen, die er gerne oder sie gerne hätte und dann müssen sie sich nochmal dadrüber streiten. Das ist jetzt das Erste, was wir gesehen haben. Da werden aber noch ein paar mehr folgen vermutlich.
Aber das ist halt wirklich so einfach nur absurd. Ähm als ich das gelesen habe, habe ich echt gedacht, das ist jetzt irgendwie.
So schön, gut, hier ist unser Kompromissvorschlag, mach das mal alles schlechter.
Ja, einfach einmal mit ohne Grundrechte bitte, weil das gibt eh nur Stress. Kann man kann man ja gar nicht so willkürlich Sachen sperren.
Okay. Und das bedeutet also der die von Seiten der Kommission ist nix zu erwarten und von Seiten des Rates ist auch nix zu erwarten.
Du meinst positiv, also für uns positiv. Nee, also der Rat hält jetzt auch einen Technologie-Experten-Workshop. Aber ohne zivilgesellschaftliche Vertreter natürlich.
Wer soll wer ist denn da eingeladen?
Das weiß man halt nicht so genau, ist halt der Rat, ne. Also im Zweifelsfall Learn Forcement ähm und äh Technology Menschen.
Machen die im Rat eigentlich nie öffentliche.
Das ist das Problem. Also bei öffentlichen Anhören weiß ich nicht, aber wenn's halt um solche Gesetzes ähm Vorhaben geht, findet ist das das das die Arbeit des Rads immer Hinterzimmer hoch zehn.
Sind die von zu Hause so gewöhnt?
Das redet uns auch keiner rein.
Irgendwie äh äh den Arbeitsmodus äh versauen lassen.
Beziehungsweise wenn's dann da doch noch anders ist, haben sie zumindest mal so einen Ort, wo sie mal unter sich sein können.
Ja, also es gab,
Es gab ein paar Leaks, die Netzpolitik ordneterweise veröffentlicht hat, zum Beispiel zu den Positionen die einzelnen Mitgliedsender im Rat eingenommen haben. Ähm,
Deutschland ist nach wie vor unklar, also es gibt die roten Linien, aber so eine offizielle Meinung gibt's nicht
also Österreich hat sich klar dagegen geäußert, die haben wahrscheinlich aus äh Kurz- äh Chat-Protokollen gelernt,
Ähm auch ähm so die einen.
Wenn der kindliche Kaiser nachher.
Ähm bei den anderen Mitgliedsländern ist es auch nach wie vor unklar und dann gibt es auch noch so ein paar Präsentationen, die Europol im Rahmen von solchen Workshops ähm vorgezeigt hat. Das hat Netzpolitik Org sich alles anscheinend ähm,
organisiert und auch netterweise für uns alle veröffentlicht.
Mhm. Aber das heißt also, Österreich ist also welche Länder vertreten da in irgendeiner Weise eine halbwegs sinnvolle Position, also äh außer Österreich.
Gibt's welche? Also jetzt gar keins?
Ja, also ich meine, äh wir haben ja noch nicht über die Faschisten gesprochen heute. Ähm also äh die skandinavischen Länder
Johansen ist Schweden, muss man zum Background sagen, finden natürlich Technologielösungen immer total toll. Also ich meine, die haben ja auch ihren ganzen elektronische Identitätenkram und so weiter und so fort. Ähm,
ähm haben sehr viel Vertrauen in Technologie und auch sehr viel Vertrauen in ihre Regierungen, dass die keine Scheiße bauen und dementsprechend ist das echt schwierig,
dagegen ähm aufzuhetzen und da gibt es auch eine ganz andere Wahrnehmung von Privatsphäre in der Zivilgesellschaft. Deswegen ist es auch schwierig, da so,
Sowas, was man sich hier in Deutschland vorstellen könnte, das das also,
gibt es da so einfach nicht diesen gesellschaftlichen Aufschrei ähm den ham man da einfach nicht. Das heißt, es ist auch sehr viel schwerer zum Beispiel skandinavische Abgeordnete unter Druck zu setzen ähm in Schweden ist jetzt eine sehr rechte Partei ähm,
gewählt worden gerade bei den letzten Wahlen. Ähm das sieht alles nicht so gut für uns aus. Hm,
Aber ähm wir versuchen unser Bestes auch da irgendwie und eine Stimmung zu machen und über natürlich die entsprechenden Organisationen zu unterstützen, die sich da um zivilgesellschaftliche Stimmung kümmern können.
Eigentlich ja ein Land, die können ja eigentlich zufrieden sein. Bisschen kühl, aber eigentlich können die doch äh die müssen ja gar nicht großartig äh Menschen hassen da. Die haben ja eigentlich schönes Wetter und eine schöne Landschaft.
Schöne Menschen.
Ja und eine und eine halbwegs funktionierendes Sozialsystem.
Na ja aber sie müssen halt Kinder schützen.
Ja, sie haben aber auch einen Kriminalitäts äh Problem gerade und es ist halt äh,
auch einen von von Migrationsthemen geprägte, politische äh Diskussion dort und das
bringt's dann halt einfach immer alles wieder schnell aus dem Ruder. Also was heute stabil gilt, das kann morgen schon ganz schön wackeln. Das haben wir hier auch schon gemerkt. Das sehen wir halt auch überall.
In Italien ist es halt so na ja, also ich meine, ich würde auf keine italienische Regierung wetten, dass sie irgendwie länger als drei Monate,
durchhält, von daher ist das unter Umständen auch so ein vorübergehendes Phänomen, auch wenn's natürlich schon so ein bisschen krass ist, dass halt dann so offen ähm.
Musst du die nie Kultur werdende Menschen äh,
überhaupt noch. Aber das hat einfach die meisten Leute denken nicht in dem Maße über Politik nach, wie wir das äh tun, sicherlich teilweise noch nicht mal im Ansatz und haben dazu keinen Bezug und die,
Leute lassen sich einfach schnell durch einzelne Themen in irgendeine Richtung bringen, die ihr eben so eine gesamtgesellschaftlichen Konsens und so ein politisches System schnell auch destabilisieren können, haben wir auch in den USA gesehen, sehen wir auch täglich in den USA, weil die Leute nicht,
begreifen, welchen Wert das für sie darstellt,
Sie halten das für etwas austauschbares, äh etwas, was ihnen nur schadet, das wird ihnen dann halt auch äh von den Populisten entsprechend eingeredet. Dann kann's halt einfach ganz schnell gehen, deswegen kann ich auch manchmal Politiker verstehen, die einfach
da so ein bisschen Ruhe ins Spiel zu bringen. Ähm gelingt natürlich nicht.
Also es sieht nicht so es sieht nicht nicht
gar nicht gut aus. Wie gesagt, das kann halt noch sein, dass wir halt irgendwie so ein bisschen Verzögerung haben, wenn die sich da um die Kompetenzen streiten. Man kann natürlich auch sagen, okay, man kann die rechtliche Basis von der ganzen Geschichte anzweifeln und sagen, okay, interner mag das jetzt vielleicht nicht so.
Dass ausschließliche Spektrum, man könnte vielleicht auch noch mal über Datenschutz in dem Zusammenhang reden, dafür gibt's auch einen Artikel und halt den man das auch aufhängen könnte. Ähm,
aber sonst, ich sage mal so, dass da wirklich so ein starkes Momentum von den Mitgliedsstaaten kommt,
ist es natürlich so wieder dieses so, wenn die Deutschen sich dagegen positionieren würden, dann würden auch keine Ahnung wahrscheinlich ähm,
vielleicht so Niederlande, Frankreich, Belgien, mitziehen, das ist genauso wie wenn Spanien sich dagegen positioniert würde, dann würde Portugal mitmachen, ähm aber dafür müsste,
Deutschland sich mal dagegen positionieren, also so richtig im Rat und so mit wir lehnen das komplett ab. Ähm was ja noch nicht passiert ist.
Ne.
Und wer wäre das in also wer müsste dann Scholz müsste Nancy Phaser einfangen, ne? Weil also die Leute, die nennen's die Phase aus dem Haus nicht rausgeworfen hat, die sitzt da jetzt auf der EU-Ebene und Kaspern das aus.
Genau, also es gibt eine im Rat und die kaspern da jetzt gerade rum.
Von denen ist nix zu erwarten. Mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen, aber man weiß ja, wer da drin sitzt.
Genau, das heißt also müsste äh Olaf Nancy mal ähm die Leviten lesen, aber die ist ja gerade damit äh mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung beschäftigt, ne, die muss ja jetzt erstmal,
basteln. Und das Allerkrasseste ist ja
Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das vom Europäischen Gerichtshof gekippt wird dieses Gesetz, wenn das kommt, ist so dermaßen hoch, weil das juristisch so ein Quatsch ist, ähm dass es sein kann, dass wir jetzt uns da irgendwie zwei Jahre drüber streiten, ob dieses Gesetz kommt,
irgendein Gesetz kommt, in welcher Form auch immer und dann zwei Jahre später das äh europäische der Europäische Gerichtshof das halt einfach einkassiert und dann haben wir
die gleiche Chance wie immer.
Aber das kennen die ja schon.
Das ist halt wieder ähm konservative Testen dann doch gerne Grenzen aus. Ähm danach wissen sie ja, was sie bauen können.
Ähm dass es so ein bisschen der Klassiker und wir sind natürlich auch wieder sehr nah an einer Wahl dran. Das hatte man ja bei ähm Terrec auch, also bei der ähm Reform für terroristische ähm,
terroristischen Content, ähm dass man das so nah an die Wahl gebaut hat, dass alle,
Abgeordneten Angst hatten sich da dran zu verbrennen und dann nicht wiedergewählt zu werden oder so. Also das hat tatsächlich System.
Okay, was was können wir jetzt, was was tun wir jetzt? Also wir haben jetzt, du hast jetzt genug schlechte Laune verbreitet, ja? Das ist jetzt irgendwie mal rüberkommen zu ähm,
Also die die der Vorschlag der Ratspräsidentschaft ist misst äh die Deutschen positionieren sich nicht, die anderen Mitgliedsländer bis auf Österreich äh verhalten sich nicht angemessen. Ähm,
was was tun wir jetzt, um daran etwas zu ändern?
Ja ähm natürlich ähm versuchen in den Ländern, was ich schon gesagt habe,
Stimmung zu machen, die ähm uns vielleicht dann doch noch helfen könnten. Ähm es gibt ja eine deutsche Kampagne und auch eine,
gesamteuropäische, weil wir aus den letzten Jahren auch gelernt haben, dass es total wichtig ist, auch in allen europäischen Ländern
den Ton zu setzen, weil in Deutschland haben wir halt in Anführungsstrichen relativ einfaches Spiel den Ton in der Gesellschaft zu setzen zu diesem Thema. Und ähm,
Das wird ähm die Website der deutschen Kampagne wird diese Woche gelauncht und es wird auch ein Kampagnenvideo geben,
von Alexander Lehmann zu diesem ganzen Thema, dass man dann sehr gut auch verbreiten kann, das wird dann auch ähm in unterschiedliche Sprachen übersetzt werden.
Und auf der EU-Ebene wird es ein ganz dickes, fettes Positionspapier vom E-Trinetz weggeben. Nochmal irgendwie, wer es nicht weiß, das ist die European Digital Rights. Das ist ähm der größte Verbund von,
digitale Menschenrechtsorganisationen in Europa.
Ähm das sind knapp über 60 Seiten, wo nochmal wirklich die juristische Analyse drin ist, die technische Analyse ähm,
alles, was ähm die Parlamentarier dann auch irgendwie so brauchen, um an die Hand genommen zu werden und eine,
gute Argumentenbasis zu haben, um das dann auch entsprechend in ihren Fraktionen diskutieren zu können. Ähm die ähm,
Liberalen werden wieder der Kingmaker sein im Zweifelsfall. Das heißt da müssen wir halt besonders dran rütteln. Ähm,
Ja, ich glaube, das war so im Wesentlichen, was gerade alles passiert, damit es besser wird und.
Und los geht's jetzt.
Los geht's jetzt, ja und dann gibt's natürlich auch irgendwie ganz viele Dinge, die man hinter den Kulissen so hin- und herschiebt, aber.
Und wie wie würdest du die Erfolgsaussichten gerade einschätzen?
Also ich habe tatsächlich große Hoffnung dadrin, dass das Ding kippt aufgrund von dieser schlechten rechtlichen Basis und dass allen klar wird, okay wir haben nichts davon, jetzt vier Jahre lang um so ein Ding zu kämpfen, um Kinder zu schützen ähm und,
tragen eigentlich nichts zum Kinderschutz bei, ähm außer, dass wir irgendwie sehr viel Zeit und sehr viel Geld darauf verschwendet haben, uns über,
Technologie zu streiten zum Beispiel. Ähm und ich hoffe, dass es ein Argument für den für das viele zugänglich sind. Ähm,
aber ansonsten habe ich echt irgendwie ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen.
Was können ähm unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer tun, um an den Bauschmerzen etwas zu ändern, ne? Also du hast jetzt gesagt, okay, Erik schreibt ein Papier
es gibt 'ne internationale Kampagne, wie kann man da seine Unterstützung mit einbringen? Ich hab immer so ein bisschen,
also ich stelle fest, ne, in dem Moment, wo wenn so Organisationen,
wie CCC oder Edri oder Epicenter oder wie sie alle heißen? Sagen, wir machen jetzt hier die Kampagne,
Das ist teilweise ein bisschen den Effekt hat, dass Menschen dann so dazu tendieren, ah super, die kümmern sich da drum,
vielleicht gebe ich da noch ein werfe ich da noch ein bisschen Geld mit rein? Aber das läuft oder auch zum Beispiel auf die Idee kommen dann einfach so hier äh,
Ihren guten Rat noch mitzugeben, was man noch alles machen kann, ja? Das ist auch immer sehr, dass es äh da da stehe ich auch total drauf.
Twitter-Avatar könnte man noch ändern.
Ihr könntet, warum macht ihr eigentlich nicht so so, ne? Warum empfehlt ihr keinen VPN? Und ähm.
Also mein Favorite ist, warum also wir können noch als CCC eigene Infrastruktur aufbauen, um die Chat-Kontrolle zu umgehen und dann ist ja alles gut.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Ja, das ist aber das ist das ist leider der gleiche äh,
Techno Solution Disson, wie bei der Chatkontrolle selber, ne? Das äh zu es muss sich hier etwas ändern. Deswegen meine Frage, ich will also ich ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass viele Menschen,
diese Geschichte als Problem sehen?
Ich bin mir sicher, dass wenn man dass sie auch sich freuen, wenn sie eine sinnvolle Perspektive bekommt, wie sie etwas dagegen tun können, wie sie beitragen können mit mehr als ihrem guten,
wichtigen Rat.
Ähm also ich glaube, was total helfen würde, wenn es Hörerinnen gibt, die andere,
Landessprachen sprechen, also zum Beispiel schwedisch oder so und auch Menschen in den Ländern kennen oder vielleicht eine Idee haben, was man da machen können, dass äh die sich ähm definitiv melden. Ähm dann ist natürlich das Thema,
Protestaktionen.
Wieder da. Ähm da ist Viktor gerade dran, das auszuarbeiten, wie das aussehen kann. Das können aber auch irgendwie vereinzelte Fotoaktionen sein
oder Ähnliches ähm wenn Personen in ähm Organisationen aktiv sind, weil ich glaube, dass es tatsächlich ein Ding, wo wir das Ding gewinnen können, die sich mit Kinderschutz-oder Betroffenenrechten beschäftigen,
die davon zu überzeugen, mal über die Chat-Kontrolle nachzudenken ähm und halt auch sich mit uns zu unterhalten ähm und auch dann sinnvolle
präventiv Vorschläge zu machen. Ähm das halte ich ähm für sehr wichtig und auf jeden Fall ein Bereich, in dem man,
machen kann, viel machen kann und es halt auch auch wirklich aktiv Leute, auch ich sehe es halt auch gerade bei bei Menschen, die so unter 20 sind, da hat das noch gar nicht so eingeschlagen, das ganze Thema. Also ich war vor,
Ja, das ist eigentlich noch viel krasser. Ähm ich war vor zwei Wochen auf der Tincon und habe mal was über die Chatkontrolle erzählt,
Und danach sind tatsächlich sehr viele Jugendliche zu mir gekommen und haben gedacht, haben so zu mir gesagt, krass,
das überhaupt nicht mitbekommen und wieso hat mir in der Schule eigentlich niemand mal erzählt, dass Datenschutz so ein scheiß Problem ist.
Tja.
Ähm die haben da wirklich gar kein Gefühl für. Das heißt so bei Jugendlichen das ist noch gar nicht auf deren Agenda und ich glaube tatsächlich, dass auch Jugendliche, also wenn ihr jetzt,
Jugendliche sei die LMP hören. Ich weiß nicht, wieso da eure Userbasis ist. Ähm.
Groß, sehr groß. Ja ja.
Die ganzen Wörter kennen.
Keine fünf Jahre nach Einführung.
Dann einfach wirklich mit euren euren Dunstkreisen zu reden, weil man muss es halt wirklich aus dieser netzpolitischen Blase rausbekommen, weil ähm wir können da natürlich alle uns nett zunicken und immer sagen, oh ja,
voll schlimm, aber wenn halt das in der breiten Gesellschaft nicht ankommt, dann haben wir ja auch nichts gewonnen. Ähm,
Es war jetzt ungefähr genauso spezifisch wie deine VPN-Angaben, aber.
Stick, wir haben das Problem zu 99Prozent abgedeckt.
Nee, wir sind hier halt keine keine äh full Servicedienstleister. Ihr müsst selber euch darum kümmern, dass es äh das auch mal eine schlechte Nachricht hier äh eine neue schlechte Nachrichten kommen, ja.
Genau. Nur hier dazu da, um darüber Witze zu machen.
Ja und was ja total lustig ist, es ist ja kein rein europäisches, also kein reines EU-Problem, das sind ja auch noch ganz viele andere Länder, also es gibt ja in in Großbritannien den das tolle Online-Safey
ähm und auch ähm in Kalifornien, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt, vor ein paar Wochen gab's den
California Kids Code, ähm in dem sie sich für ein Design von allen Webseiten ausgesprochen haben. Das heißt, dass ähm,
ganze Internet ähm angemessen für Kinder immer überall funktionieren soll.
Oh, super.
Ähm.
Vorne wollte nicht mitmachen.
Ähm und dass ähm dass die Design Experience für die Userinnen ähm orientiert sein muss an deren Astimated Age?
Was total lustig.
Auf einmal, dann kriegt der Tim nur noch so ein Internet mit ganz großer Schrift.
Klicken Sie hier,
Sie oft nachts raus.
Ey, das ist tatsächlich so, also.
Könnte auch auf hohes Alter hin.
Oder auf Hundewelpen.
Also es sind nicht nur ist nicht nur die äh die EU-Kommission, die da ähm wilde Sachen aus äh bastelt. Also ähm
eine eine Aktivistin aus äh aus Großbritannien hat dazu gesagt, Fighting äh ready good idea.
Weil was natürlich durch diese ganzen Gesetze geschaffen wird, ist die Motivation für irgendwelche Startup-Fritzen irgendwelche Technologien zu bauen, um ähm,
Age Verification zu machen mit
biometrischen Daten oder was weiß ich nicht was, Fragebögen, wie oft müssen Sie nachts raus? Ich weiß es nicht. Ähm und äh das ist natürlich super gefährlich. Also wir wollen irgendwie diese ganzen großen Plattformen regulieren, zurecht an einigen Stellen, aber was wir halt,
irgendwie gerade sehen von den Gesetzgebern, sind halt irgendwie so Policys, die immer Verschlüsselung untergraben wollen,
Ähm und ähm irgendwie die Anonymität im Internet äh aufheben wollen und äh also das ist wirklich.
Also bei bei dieser EU kommen Geschichte, dass dann auch noch irgendwie so ein so ein Start-up dahinter hängt mit einem Hollywood-Schauspieler, das ist wirklich also,
Wenn du dir so, wenn du dir so Polittstriller anschaust, ne, irgendwie so Westwing,
House of Cards und denkst dir immer so, er ist doch irgendwie bescheuert, das kann doch gar nicht sein, dass es so was von überzogen, ne? Und jetzt rennt hier echt ein Kutscher, macht Werbung in irgendwelchen,
Aerobic Videos.
Für seine Kinderschutzorganisation wohlgemerkt,
Also es.
Schützenserik.
Wird Präsident, also das ist alles, ich meine.
Es ist wirklich furchtbar und ich meine, also das sieht man jetzt tatsächlich auch. Also in den in den in Großbritannien gibt es jetzt schon einen boomenden Markt ähm von Tech Industry, Start-ups, die Algorithmen bauen, um Kindesmissbrauchsmaterialien ähm,
zu detekten. Genauso wie ähm Altersverifikation und Content-Blocking.
Altersverifikation ist ein relativ einfach. Wenn man's ordentlich machen würde, aber lassen wir das.
Na ja, hm ja, fangen fangen wir nicht an, dass sonst sitzen wir morgen noch.
Weißt du was das heißt?
Und dann und dann irgendjemand und.
Übersetzen Sie dieses Wort. Aber dann haben Sie das ein Problem ist, die kennen dann die anderen Wörter nicht.
Dann auch dann irgend so ein so ein Klugscheißer, der's dann unbedingt googeln will und dann auf nichts mehr zugreifen kann.
Jetzt hast gegoogelt. Puma.
Ja also wie gesagt, es ist alles irgendwie ähm furchtbar, aber was soll man machen? Das ist ja irgendwie schon immer.
Ja willkommen zu unserem Grundgefühl.
Ja, ich freue mich total jetzt auch zu dieser Gruppe zu gehören.
Passt doch oder?
Herzlich willkommen.
Ich weiß, ihr wollt alle in Rente gehen.
Wer ich? So weit's noch nicht.
Weiß ich nicht, wer in Rente gehen will. Also ich meinte in Rente im Sinne von sich nicht mehr mit diesen Themen auseinander.
Ach so, ja, der kann's ja auch irgendwie dran gewöhnen. Mir würde was fehlen irgendwie.
Je je näher ja.
Wäre langweilig dann, ne? Wisst ihr gar nicht, was du machen sollst.
Im Moment, weißt du, hier mit diesem Podcast, das hält den Tim halt vom Fenster weg, ne, sonst wird der halt am Fenster sitzen und die ganze Zeit meckern, was draußen passiert.
Nicht irgendwie so.
Der Hund hier schon wieder hin. Hör auf Fußball zu spielen hier mitten auf der Straße. So weißt du so.
Also hat auf jeden Fall positive Wirkung, kann man nicht abstreiten.
Ist gut für den Blutdruck.
Ja für noch, noch ist es noch, macht der Blutdruck das mit,
Kommen wir mal, ich hatte ja gesagt zum zum E-Rezept wird es neues äh neue Nachrichten geben und die gibt es auch,
Und zwar geht es spezifisch. Ähm wir haben jetzt ja in der vorletzten Sendung damit unterhalten über den Abruf der E-Rezepte in der Apotheke nach Autorisierung.
Das ist der Prozess, in dem du dein Rezept da vorlegst und die,
Krankenkassenkarte dafür vorlegst, ja so oder beziehungsweise das hier ist deine Krankenkassenkarte und dann können die sehen, welche Rezepte vorliegen und dann hast du so ein richtig schönes Online-Ding. Und in diesem Ding,
In diesem Teil, da hatten da hat mir das auch äh behandelt, dass,
Der E-Rezept-Fachdienst der GEMAtik, den brauchst du nur eine Krankenversichertennummer zu geben, die KVNR.
Und die, so sieht es diese spezifizierte Dienst vor, sollst du bekommen von der Krankenkassenkarte.
Allerdings muss die Apotheke nicht,
einen Nachweis mitliefern, dass diese Karte überhaupt tatsächlich gerade bei ihr war. Das heißt, jede äh Mitarbeiterin einer Apotheke kann zu einer Krankenversicherungsnummer,
die ähm E-Rezepte einsehen. Und,
dieser Aspekt, den hatte äh hat ein hat der Flipkey ja äh insbesondere in der Pressemitteilung des CCC auch bemängelt, ne.
Und jetzt gibt es eine schöne Nachricht vom Bundesbeauftragten für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit,
an, die Gematik,
Zur Feature Spezifikation Abruf der E-Rezepte in der Apotheke nach Autorisierung. Klammer auf, ursprüngliche Bezeichnung Abruf der E-Rezepte in der Apotheke mit personenbezogenem Identitätsnachweis. Da haben sie nämlich dann geändert
Weil sie gesehen haben, personenbezogene Identitäts haben wir hier im weitesten Sinne nicht. So, jetzt schreibt der,
Bundesbeauftragte für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit. Bezugnehmend auf meine E-Mail vom 1. September teile ich ihn mit, dass das BFTI zu den von Ihnen am 29. August versandten Festlegung der,
Feature-Spezifikation. Das prüfende zu prüfende Einvernehmen nicht erteilen kann.
Deutscher Fritz.
Ja auch nicht so einfach mit diesem.
Frischen Fisch.
Sieht vor, dass halt Abruf von E-Rezepten aus dem E-Rezept Fachdienst unter Nutzung der Krankenversichertennummer und eines unsignierten Prüfungsnachweises der Versicherten, Stammdaten, Management Dienstes ermöglicht werden soll,
Der unsignierte Prüfungsnachweis ist prinzipiell manipulierbar und könnte Angreifer in den unberechtigten Zugang zum E-Rezept-Fachdienst mit den dort gespeicherten E-Rezepten ermöglichen
Das BSI ich schreibe ein bisschen das BSI hält den Mangel ebenfalls für so gravierend, dass kein dass es kein Einvernehmen erteilen wird.
Als Lösung schlage ich vor zeitnah ein Verfahren zu spezifizieren, dass das Signieren des Prüfnachweises vorsieht. Begründung,
die Begründung haben wir hier geliefert. Äh am Ende kann jetzt jeder Person in der Apotheke für jeden,
Für jede Krankenversicherungsnummer einfach die ähm,
die Rezepte einsehen, weil hier einfach kein kein Prüfungsnah also keine Identitätsprüfung und auch keine Autorisierungsprüfung,
stattfindet.
Sehr geil ist da noch, dass die Money-Quote in der längeren Begründung als mögliche Lösung schlage ich vor, ein Verfahren zu spezifizieren, dass das Signieren des Prüfnachweises vorsieht. Sollte dies aufgrund der vorliegenden IT-Architektur nicht mit vertretbarem Aufwand möglich sein
berate ich Sie gerne zur alternativen Ansätzen. Der sagt sogar noch egal was ihr wollt, ich helfe euch noch, aber das können wir so
nicht akzeptieren. Und dieser Teil, ja,
ähm der der hier bemängelt wird durch den durch das BSI und durch den oder durch das Bundesamt für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit. Das ist genau der Teil,
der ähm den der CCC kritisiert hat und wo Like deacon,
Der ähm äh ich glaube irgendwie gematikisch noch dazu geschrieben hat, wir haben das bewusst so gemacht,
quasi absichtlich gesagt, man würde die Prüfung,
Frontend vornehmen statt im Back-End, was immer wenn jemand sagt, ey das prüfen wir einfach im Fronten-End, kannst du sofort sagen, nein
Nein, das wurde nicht im Fronted. So sonst hast du nämlich die Zerforschung äh in in deinem.
Sollten wir in die deutschen Oberstunde.
So sieht's aus.
Äh das ist auch so äh also das ist doch.
Ja
Ist so. Ja, das wird also falsche Systemarchitektur wird sofort mit zur Forschung bestraft.
Die Armen sind schon total überlastet, weil keiner richtig.
Mal einer an die Jugendlichen.
Ne? Aber wir haben ja hier in der in der Folge dazu noch diskutiert. Tim, da meintest du ja noch irgendwie, ah, da ist alles ich kann mir hier meine Baldriparan beim Doc Morris bestellen.
Nee, nee, das äh BFTI und BSI anders und das jetzt bin ich auch durch mit den mit den Abkürzungen hier.
Auf jeden Fall ähm sehr schön und ähm das äh,
Ja, es ist sehr so schön formuliert hier, ne? Der Missbrauchsanreiz ist vor dem Hintergrund eines zentralen E-Rezeptespeichers für alle deutschen Versichertenpersonen sehr hoch. Das Eintrittsrisiko ist angesichts von über
18.000 Apotheken in Deutschland, das sind die mit den gefälschten Impfnachweisen, ne? Ähm ähm
unterschiedlich stark aufgestellter IT-Sicherheit ebenfalls sehr hoch. Ja, sehr schön.
Ja wo wir gerade über Gesundheitsdaten sprechen, die EU macht da jetzt was eigenes.
Wie kommt das?
Na ja, also die haben sich überlegt, da sind ja so viele Daten und das wäre ja total sinnvoll, also die sind ja auch liegen auch so in unterschiedlichen Formaten, je nach,
Mitgliedsländern vor, aber damit könnte man ja so toll Forschung betreiben, ähm auch im Mai zusammen mit der Chatkontrolle, deswegen wahrscheinlich auch einfach ein bisschen untergegangen, wurde der European Health Dataspace for,
gestellt, also ein europäischer Gesundheitsdatenraum. Der ähm,
Also alle Dienstleister, egal ob Krankenkasse, irgendwelche Wellnessanbieterinnen oder so ähm dazu bringen ähm.
Elektronische Gesundheitsakten, zum Beispiel Patientenakten und Abrechnungsdaten an eine erstmal national zentrale Stelle zu übermitteln, die dann auch eine sekundäre Nutzung ähm der,
Daten außerhalb des Behandlungsverhältnis ähm ermöglicht,
Kurz zu diesem Thema Sekundäre und primäre Verwendung von elektronischen Gesundheitsdaten. Primär bedeutet, dass sie halt für das verwendet werden, für dass wir die auch unsere Anbieterinnen gegeben haben. Also,
Zur Abrechnung von irgendwelchen Rezepten.
Et cetera und die sekundäre Verwendung von solchen Gesundheitsdaten ähm beschreibt dann sozusagen das zugänglich machen dieser Daten für die Forschung. Ähm,
und das ist natürlich ähm höchst kritisch zu sehen, ähm weil ja nach wie vor die Frage im Raum steht,
ja so genetische Daten oder Sachen, die man vielleicht nicht so möchte generell, ähm wie die halt anonymisiert, pseudonymisiert und sonst irgendwas äh werden können. Ähm
Ja und das macht also die EU baut da jetzt mal was eigenes, sodass wir das halt ähm gesamt-europäisch mal sammeln können.
Ah, das ist ja eine super Idee, ne. Da kann ja eigentlich auch wenig was schief gehen. Wenn jetzt,
Ausgerechnet die Leute, die an an die Chatkontrolle glauben, sagen wir machen jetzt am besten noch eine europäische Zentraldatenbank für Gesundheitsdaten.
Ja, also ich weiß, also es geht dir natürlich zu sagen natürlich, es geht ihnen darum, dass man dann so grenzübergreifend besser, ne, also wenn du in Portugal ins Krankenhaus gehst, dann ist das natürlich dann viel besser für dich, weil dann können sie ja auch auf deine Gesundheitsdaten zugreifen. Ähm ja.
Ist ja auch ein Aspekt. Also ich meine, das würde man ja im Zweifelsfall auch wollen, ne.
Ja, die Frage ist natürlich, ob so eine zentralisierte europäische Lösung,
das Beste ist und das ist ja auch nach wie vor ein Vorschlag und ähm ich meine ja.
Okay, also das wird das wird auch noch Thema. Wer kümmert sich darum? Noch niemand.
Also ich würde jetzt äh genau, noch niemand ähm ich habe es im Blick, aber ich bin natürlich nicht in einer Detailtiefe da drin, wie ich jetzt vielleicht in der Chatkontrolle gerade stecke.
Der wir also jetzt auf jeden Fall einfach mal schön zu sehen, dass dass man dass man hier vorgewarnt wird, ja? Das ist ja bei Logbuch Netzpolitik tatsächlich so. Ihr werdet vorgewarnt,
Die sich als nächstes ausdenken, dann äh hört ihr euch das jetzt zwei Jahre an und denkt, oh und dann irgendwann.
Ist ja tatsächlich eingeschlagen, die Acellerie-Munition, die da abgeschickt wurde.
Ich möchte abschließend noch mal ein paar äh Worte zu der allgemeinen Zeit verlieren.
Wir haben das, glaube ich, hier in der Sendung jetzt noch gar nicht äh äh überhaupt gewürdigt, das jetzt Nord Stream eins und Nord Stream zwei mit äh nennenswerten Löchern versehen sind und in die Ostsee blubbern.
Was jetzt auch nicht so toll ist.
Ist nicht so toll, ne? Auch keine gute Nachricht. Hätten wir eigentlich mit in die Sendung.
Ja mhm.
Während äh sage ich mal die kriegerische Situation in vielen Ländern dieser Erde jetzt auch nicht unbedingt darauf hoffen lässt, dass sie bald vorbei ist,
ähm und während in Italien, Brasilien, USA, Schweden und so weiter natürlich die Faschisten wieder die Gunst der Stunde riechen,
und sich als äh in einer Welt mit zunehmenden, größeren Schwierigkeiten und Komplexitäten mit sehr einfachen Lösungen äh bereitstellen wollen,
und das macht auch die AFD in Deutschland, die am 8. Oktober,
in Deutsch, in Berlin zu einer Großdemonstration eingeladen hat. Das letzte Mal, dass sie zu einer Großdemonstration eingeladen haben, war im Mai zwanzig achtzehn,
und ähm ich kann sagen, da hat äh Berlin sich sehr schön,
gegen äh Gegendemonstriert, sehr viele natürlich zu aufgerufen. Mein Lieblingsaufruf äh war unter dem Motto AfD wegbassen?
Und ähm das Poster war so eine bunte Tablette mit äh Antifa-Logo,
stand eben. Hauptsache es knallt AfD-Vektor und es war die Einladung zur antifaschistischen After Hour.
Was äh dann natürlich mit lauter Musik und so ein schöner äh bunter Gegenprotest gegen die AfD. Dieses Mal ziert äh gibt's wieder ein breites Bündnis. Ähm,
und dieses Mal ziert das Plakat ähm von Reclam Club Culture zwei Tabletten,
ähnlich bunt Antifa heißt nachlegen,
Doppelt hält besser. Äh finde ich beides sehr gelungen für äh bestimmte Vorurteile über die Berliner äh Partyszene und das Ganze findet jetzt also am 8. Oktober in Berlin statt,
und ich denke ja, das Wetter ist äh nicht ganz so cool wie im Mai und äh insofern wär's schon relativ wichtig,
Termin dann auch im Kalender zu haben und daran teilzunehmen, weil grade in in den jetzigen Zeiten muss tatsächlich so,
beängstigend sie sind und sie auch inzwischen lange beängstigend sie sind ähm.
Klar gemacht werden, dass äh ja wir leider, leider, leider mal wieder Leute brauchen, die mit einer Komplexität umgehen können und die nicht aus ähm,
aus der Komplexität dem Drang auf einfache Antworten nachgeben und die Vollidioten wählen.
Deswegen möchte ich das noch mal besonders hervorheben, bevor wir grundsätzlich zu den ähm Terminen kommen.
Auch mit musikalischer Begleitung.
Wenn du möchtest, auch mit musikalischer Begleitung.
Völlig überraschend. 8112 Uhr in Berlin Mitte Aufstehen gegen Rassismus. Ich habe den Link in den Shownotes. Überall in Berlin mit äh der AfD entgegentreten.
Am oh diese falschen Reihenfolge,
am vom 22. bis 23. Oktober findet in der Archenholzsternwatte in Berlin Triptow die pfiffcon statt,
Wurde uns äh angepriesen als klassisches Friedensthema aber schwurbelfrei. Kann man also.
Das muss man heutzutage dazu sagen.
Ähm Konferenz findet unter dem Motto make install piece Impulse für den Frieden statt und äh findet sich an der Schnittstelle zwischen Informatik und Friedensforschung eben den klassischen Fifthheben.
Programm ist bereits verfügbar und genau 21. bis 23. Oktober in Berlin,
Am 12.11. EP-Release,
von Systemabsturz, die haben einen neuen Song, den sie dann da wo sie dann da ihre EP releasen.
Mhm und wo? In der Sea Base.
In der Seaways und dass dieser EP-Release findet statt quasi als Vorband von Rosa Luxus, die danach äh auflegen wird.
So so. Exklusiv.
Luxuriös.
Das wird äh ein ein großer Spaß in der Cines. Ich glaube, das sind die das sind die Termine, die wir heute für euch haben.
Okay. Und das war dann äh sozusagen damit auch äh die Themenwelt, die wir heute diese Woche für euch haben, oder?
Könnt ja echt mal wieder ein schönes Thema gebrauchen.
Andere Leier. Na, denk dir was aus. Gucken. Also ansonsten nehmen wir jetzt.
Überlegt, ob ich einen Wirtschafts-Podcast mache, aber dann gibt's auch keine schönen Themen.
Wirtschaftsüberwachs.
Überfallende Kurven so.
Ich bleibe erstmal noch eine Weile bei Krieg und dann.
Ja, da gibt's ja auch sehr schön, ne? Also bei Tim gibt's auch bei UKW gibt's so gute Nachrichten. Atomkrieg nicht vor Weihnachten. Toll.
Man muss immer das Positive sehen.
Wenn wir ein Tonkred haben, dann haben wir wenigstens keine Ted-Kontrolle.
Äh ich glaube, das geht auch Hand in Hand. Khalesi, vielen Dank fürs Kommen.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Ja und deine äh deine dein Zugriff auf den europäischen ähm Gesetzesprozess,
die du ja auch hast, den mentalen Zugriff hast du zumindest gucken was wir da noch bewegen können, aber wissen ja auch immer die Sachen, die äh am Ende kommt ja dann doch oft äh auch ins Trudeln.
Darauf ist zu hoffen, vielleicht sind Eva Johansen und äh Ursula ja irgendwann mal weg und vielleicht finden die Nachfolger den Gesetzentwurf dann doof.
Ich glaube die Osli bleibt erstmal noch eine Weile.
Die letzte, ja die haben wir schon oft uns also der für die haben wir uns schon oft ein Stoppschild gewünscht, aber die ist auf der Datenautobahn unterwegs.
Schiene.
All right. Wir sagen tschüss, bis bald und wir hören uns äh nächste Woche oder so.
Ciao.